you did a reddit AMA I think and you
said that art saved your life yes oh my
god you should you actually Wow I love
you you've done homework yes I did a
reddit AMA it was something that was
recommended that I do and and I
personally myself as an artist and as an
entrepreneur which I'll talk about that
in a minute because I think it's
important I I think it's important to
constantly push my boundaries in my
comfort zone and my parameters that
expand my horizons see what's out there
so I did this AMA on reddit and I did
say that art did save my life because it
did that's a long story that's a longer
answer but I'm happy to talk about it
kee do a Reader's Digest version The
Reader's Digest version boy we're gonna
dive right in okay I'm not giving away
my age there so The Reader's Digest
version okay so the Reader's Digest
version i zigged when I should have
zagged and I got caught up in this kind
of New Age doomed a doomsday cult and
took about 20 years out of my life yeah
Wow exactly exactly okay yeah so by all
means I shouldn't vote by many
parameters definitions etc I shouldn't
be able to be like doing as well as I
can but that's you know I've been
working at things so why did we get on
that question
oh the AMA Arts saved my life so in that
process of getting myself out of that
cult and the brainwashing the mind
control whatever you want to call it
that goes with it
I always wanted to be a performer I
always loved the arts singing dancing
acting writing playing music all of it
you know I loved it but I just didn't
get the support that I needed to keep
pursuing that and then you know there
are other things that happen in life
along the way and so I like I just went
full bore into acting and you know you
work you work it out in an acting class
you know it's a safe space
hopefully sometimes it's not and you've
got to look out for that
but you know it it encourages and
enables the person the individual to be
able to explore you know some dark
territory some dark emotions some taboo
emotions some dangerous places
emotionally some some weird places
whatever it may be and you know
subsequently that helped me in ways that
I didn't even really understand I didn't
go there and go well it's gonna be
therapy for me or whatever but it
certainly it certainly was the case for
me and yeah man it did it saved my life
it really did yeah so without going too
much into the cold yeah were you did you
have another career that you were doing
before uh I did
I was yeah I guess for I've kind of
always had an entrepreneurial spirit
ever since I was a little boy I'm like a
boy I asked my dad if I could use the
lawn mower when I was I don't know it
was like seven or eight years old and he
looked at me he's like why so nice I
want to go mow some lawns and he just
kind of smiled he was okay and so I just
went down the street and started
knocking on my neighbor's doors hey you
know I'm on your lawn for you didn't
have a price or anything in mind I just
think I was just like the kindness of
people and I'd go out there and mow the
lawn and rake it up and put it in
plastic bags and like I'm seven or eight
years old I thought that's you know I
saw that's how my father did it and
that's how you're supposed to do it
that's how it was done and invariably
everybody would be staring out their
windows just watching this young kid
like working then they was come here so
diligent I didn't know what that meant
you know you're so thorough this is
great and they would give me five and
ten dollars which you know back in those
days was a lot of money and it became
quickly apparent to me that you know
this was something I like to do I
enjoyed the whole every aspect of it the
the hustle the the drive that go out
knock you have to create something and
then follow through and and provide the
service and do a good job and make the
customer happy and hopefully they'll
tell somebody else you come back
again this was way more fun than going
and saying you know hey can I scoop ice
cream err and there's not that there's
anything wrong with that but for me the
way I was wired that that's always been
what I did so yeah I had I've owned and
operated several businesses most of them
not successfully but that's where you
learn you know you fall down flat on
your face and lose money just screw the
pooch in any number of ways and you know
you you know that didn't work I won't do
that again and you start to learn all
that worked I'll do more of that I'll
just keep doing that and yeah that's
that's been what I've done so at that
time I'd had a we started at ironically
in that cult we started a painting
business and and we were kind of
struggling and then threw out the idea
that you know maybe we should go after
the affluent market where people who
have a lot of money and they don't
necessarily worry about price so much as
they do the quality of the work and and
you not being a pain in their backside
and so we started to go after the
big-name designers this was in New York
City at the time in the 80s and yeah we
got a couple of designers gave us a
break and we got a chance to do like one
bedroom for I'm not gonna start naming
names but for some very affluent clients
and they liked it and word started to
spread and within a year we had more
work than we could handle and we had we
were booked out you know months in
advance and you know when you our whole
thing was doing a great job like doing a
job that they didn't expect going above
and beyond and like I said you know I
learned this when I was like eight years
old so you know I showed up at this one
very wealthy woman woman's apartment she
owned like the entire and I was like the
tenth floor of a very well-known
building in the Upper West Side and I
walked in and this was the gig man this
is that I knew I knew what to do I just
I knew from all these trial and error
that she wanted her place to look
pristine and you walk in it was gorgeous
it was absolutely beautiful not my style
but tasteful elegant beautiful and we're
gonna repaint the place so I walked in
with a disposable camera took pictures
to all around the room and I the entire
apartment and I asked the maid or the
housekeeper excuse me ask the
housekeeper if I could be excused I
needed to go develop the film and she
looked at me like I what and she said
well let me go ask mrs. and I said okay
and so I did and they gave me the
blessing and I went down to the our film
developing I came back and I put
everything into all the pictures inside
of a photo album and they're watching me
out of the corner of my eye and I was
like I got him and it was method to my
madness but it was also you know I
wanted to let them know just they could
just start to relax and that tension on
their shoulders could start to dissipate
and then I got the other guys that were
with me and we started to just mask off
the floor with first we put down sisal
paper they call it the brown kind of
absorbent paper and we taped off every
square inch of the floor right and then
we put plastic over that we put another
layer of drop cloth over that like the
floor wasn't going to get damaged and
they're just looking at me out of the
corner like very good very good so
anyway I don't know why we're talking
about that but yeah that's that was the
level of work that we did and we did
well we did well with it but at some
point you decided that sorry there was a
lot of insanity going on as I said
because that was the business and that
was the face of you know that was our
business but then like the insanity of
that group was always an undercurrent
all the time and like that's a whole
other story I mean we would talk about
that for hours but yes but at some point
you said you know what I want to try
this acting thing I will I always did
and I kind of dabbled in it from it from
a distance
and but I was really you know honestly I
was just petrified to do it I was afraid
to put myself you know on camera you
know your first time you see yourself on
camera I think this goes for pretty much
everyone you just oh my god oh my god
you just start beating yourself up which
doesn't do anybody any good alright
but it's shocking the first time you
hear your voice and you see yourself on
camera and how you do things and how you
say things and it cetera so I I really
went all-in and I got really lucky right
away and got my Screen Actors Guild card
with pretty much my first audition Wow I
know I know that rarely if ever happens
was on a show that used to be shot down
in San Diego with Stu Segal productions
Stu is a great guy had studio set up
down there and he did a show called silk
stockings yes 18 wheels of justice was
the other one wings of gold something I
can't remember I can't really shop those
shows down there and I got my first my
first gig working with Rob Estes and
Mindy I forgot Mindy's last name sorry
Mindy really great actors great people
on silk stockings yeah
so then how was it for you no cuz you're
you're living off that high and maybe
the paycheck of the job but then the
weird part is then who then it comes
down and now you're drumming up work and
now that clock is ticking for the first
of the month you know what's interesting
about that you're right
you're right that occurred and I had a
bunch of crazy notions in my head about
you know what acting was and what you
know the what what what would happen you
know like all these crazy ideas of
celebrity and money and stardom and
stuff that wasn't what I was aiming for
but the funny thing was you just hit the
nail on the head you know if you're
gonna succeed in this business whatever
if you're going to be writing directing
producing acting singing dancing
whatever it is whatever aspect it's
contingent upon your ability
to keep picking up the phone keep
sending the emails following up going to
networking events or going to meetings
or whatever you get out there and start
to circulate in nurturing relationships
and I did that in business but for
whatever reason when I got into acne was
just like hi I'm here and I'm not sure
why I did that the only thing I can
think the reason that I may have done
that was because it was so therapeutic
in so many ways there was less judgment
in the beginning stages at least through
these eyes there were you know when
you're in an acting class like it was a
very forgiving space largely and that
was like holy Sh this is you know my
heart just like started to open up this
is fantastic
and you can get weird like I said you
can get funny you get serious you get
loud you get ugly
whatever right tender powerful whatever
it may be and and I think I well I
needed that clearly I needed that and I
turned off the business part of my brain
and I wish I hadn't but you know
everyone's path is different that's not
the case these days but it certainly
wasn't the beginning you said something
interesting you said that in the
beginning it was a safe space and that
people were encouraging or you just felt
like accepted do you think as you rise
in the ranks that changes yeah it can of
course I mean that's very kind of naive
on my part and it's also accurate you
know you can't create a performance in a
place where you don't feel safe and yet
this isn't anything that no one's I
heard a million times you got to be you
got to feel comfortable and safe with
your director with the crew members with
producers with you know screenwriter
with the whoever it is you got to feel
that you know we're all in this together
we're trying to create something
and but you know as necessarily as you
as you start working on bigger and
bigger projects you know you're stepping
into a business and if they're
successful ones if they've been around a
long time there are well oiled machine
and you're just there to move a
storyline along or you're there to play
you know whatever X Factor is in that
story in that script in the parameters
of that show and those characters in
that world and you know if you forget
that not not a resource we'll know so
but but but I I think that yeah it still
can be a safe space but of course then
you know it's it's it's commerce you're
in business so you have to you have to
factor that in I believe that that
doesn't happen often enough with a lot
of actors well you know to be fair
actors take a beating all the time
because they think like you know we call
talking and moving background some guy
said one time I looked I was like really
wow that's amazing you feel comfortable
enough to say that to me what was your
name again I didn't catch it right but
you have to often actors I I have seen
too often that they will not embrace
business aspect but as I said to be fair
I see writers doing the same thing I see
directors doing the same thing I see
some producers doing the same thing
which seems counterintuitive but they it
happens I've seen it happen they don't
take the business aspect into play
enough it is called show business and
really it should probably go up the
business of show because if you want to
create or perform whatever your art is
whatever your your your instrument your
vehicle is for for expressing your your
artistry you can do it on any street
corner right but if we're here in
Hollywood then necessarily you are
looking to make a mark make a statement
and be paid for it and that's great but
you if you
to do that then you need to understand
how businesses work after you got going
a little while was it more important for
you to find a manager or an agent or
work on your craft yes yeah yeah
interest that's a grits a good question
I did all three as a bit you know I just
I was like slow to bring my business
acumen into you know the my acting
business that sounds crazy to say but
anyway I didn't see any sense in getting
a manager and an agent when there wasn't
anything needing a manager yet there was
no career there is no career right I
mean I guess you probably still say that
now in a manner of speaking
kidding not really but I am uh uh you
know why give away another ten percent
of your income for what right and if
it's a manager the managers dynamic
should be one of supporting and
nurturing your you and your career and
what is possible and what is available
and what could be created right
so I didn't spend a lot of time with
that agents yeah you know we all chase
agents all the time but the guy you know
me right now I would say don't worry
about the agent especially in today's
market you don't necessarily need an
agent get your hustle on submit for
anything and everything you can show up
keep auditioning keep getting better
work on your craft absolutely but you
know you want to get so good at it you
want the muscle memory the emotional
muscle memory the the the auditioning
muscle memory the you know get ready to
cry at the drop of a dime or whatever
may be happening you got to get those
things so they're prepared and ready to
go
and then you know the darndest thing
happens is the agents start calling you
because your work starts to show up and
mutation starts to get built and a word
starts to go around you know
conversations start to happen and then
what you've done is you flip the script
and it's really the smart thing to do
quite frankly
just real quick following up something
you said you just joked about there not
being a career do you feel like that
every time one job ends because you are
essentially it's like a snow globe
you're shaking it up you know yeah
absolutely
oh my god yeah I remember what had
happened but I was talking with someone
who had the kind of typical
oh you're working in TV and film oh my
god and I'm thinking you know man I'm on
set the lights are on the cameras going
the mics hot the crews standing around
they're setting up the shot changing you
know a lens relighting something
whatever it is there's a little bit of a
break I've got my cell phone out and I'm
answering emails I'm sending off texts
looking for work returning phone calls
if I've got a second without
interrupting everybody else and then put
it away and go right back into it you
know hustling right on the set in the
trailer in the makeup chair right it
never ends so yeah I always feel like
that I think every actor can I've never
heard an actor not saying that unless I
mean you're lucky enough you get you
know your own show or you have a proper
you know movie career where your keeps
on coming but even then it's it's an up
and down you just never know you know
that being said why do you think people
fail at it then fail at having
consistent acting work it's a big
question there are a number of factors
at play but if I kind of pull out and
take the meta view of it or like the
30,000 foot view like if you're in a
plane 35,000 foot whatever it may be
I think people probably aren't clear on
what they want and I also think that
most people don't investigate themselves
and know themselves well enough and
don't
manage their emotional states better
because you know ultimately everything's
a psychological game ultimately right
because you know we're all out there and
everybody here is talented like
everyone's talented ridiculously
talented the competition level is high
right and it was like that I played
college sports and it was like then it
got to I'm gonna forget when I got to
college you know I played football like
oh my god these guys were all so good
Wow right and so then it becomes a
mental game right a psychological game
managing your emotions staying focused
you know making sure you're not giving
some kind of crazy meaning to something
that happened that doesn't help you
doesn't serve you and push you down the
field or down the path towards whatever
it is you want being clear your goal and
that you notice when you start to you
know go off course maybe you have crazy
emotional reaction to something or or it
gives you a bad feeling or whatever
right so those those things are
important and I think that's a
long-winded answer but that's why more
people aren't as successful as they
could be and work more often generally
speaking that's like that is a big
question but generally speaking I would
say we start there you know it just
looked at a book just recently and it
was called I won't say who the person
was cuz I don't want to sort of break
their anonymity even though there's a
book out about them but they basically
said it was the female so-and-so who was
basically they used the male version
trying to say that this person could
have become that if they could hadn't
managed their emotions different things
drinking was another one I said and so
they showed this person's rise from sort
of obscurity and was like the poor
relation and to their subsequent
downfall and just how sad it was but I
thought that was interesting because
there could be a metaphor for a lot of
people and it's it is managing because
crazy things can happen in LA absolutely
and and I like what you said sort of
like I'm not sure if you said don't not
overreacting or managing that and
there's a skill it is a skill and in and
you know it's one that you you have to
work at to develop
it's not something we're taught you know
like that would be a really really like
critical foundational course that should
be in the educational system if you're
asking me I don't know that you are but
you know that's a life skill that's
invaluable and you know I I've got my my
my my nerdiness and one of the things is
I always like to study people who have
been you know massively successful or
influential and across a broad spectrum
of disciplines and industries and and
there's what let me ask you what do you
think would be the common the common
denominator with the most successful
people and I know that's what a
successful mean so let's just say
financially you know spiritually
emotionally psychologically physically
the most successful people what would
you think is the most common trait that
they have from what I've seen I think
people that are just obsessed with
something it doesn't even mean that
they're good people
or that you know anywhere on the
spectrum of sort of intentions but I
think being so obsessed with whatever
they are into whether it's acting
whether it's stock trading whether it's
real estate whether it's painting
whether it's meditation I've seen people
that just have this laser focus with
something and they're obsessed with the
immigrants their life this week that is
a very common answer and that's
certainly excuse me that's certainly
necessary you know the the seminal book
that Napoleon Hill wrote Think and Grow
Rich you have to have that burning
desire right white-hot burning desire
which in today's worlds like I'm
obsessed
everybody says obsessed it's not
necessarily the best word to use but
it's the word of the day so yes that's
it but but the the the trait that people
see that's that's kind of a given is
self compassion so sort of um
self-awareness or or of compassion
compassion can you can you take me
through that what that would be sure
self empathy so not beating up on
oneself there you go
interesting I would not have guessed
that
well neither would i but you all do from
just reading and studying different
people male/female different industries
different disciplines different races
origins you're gonna make mistakes you
are going to write so since we're
talking about acting and within this
film courage and writing there's a lot
of writers that watch this and I mean
what writer do you know that doesn't
beat themself up what actor do you know
that doesn't beat themself up right
right like there's that neurosis that's
always like sitting on your shoulder
here you know that anxiety is over here
and just like oh my god were they
thinking about me like give yourself a
break relax all right because reality is
most everyone not even thinking about
you that's true yeah they're thinking
about themselves
pS they're having the same conversation
you are and they're thinking you're
thinking that about them right right
we're all human beings
all right give yourself a break you're
doing the best you can do with what you
have at that time and if you are
obsessed as we say or you have that
burning desire whatever it may be then
just trust that you're gonna make
mistakes but that's how you learn
mistakes are a great thing I never used
to think that way if I sound I wonder
how that's sounds probably crazy just to
say that but it's the truth mistakes
mistakes are a blessing man number one
it means you're still alive you got
problems you're still alive there's an
old story some guy was taking a guy and
his son are driving through town and
kids talking about problems problems
problems you know Dan I just wish I'd
have any problems they drive by the
graveyard he goes you don't know one
place they don't have problems he points
to the graveyard those problems are good
they're assign a life son so yeah yeah
it's the truth though right you're gonna
make mistakes that's how you learn man
that's how you learn pain is the
greatest teacher there is and everyone
runs from it to their detriment myself
included right I find that very
interesting so instead of let's suppose
you bomb an audition or someone tells
you you're horrible whatever
I've never done it so I don't know that
can instead of sort of reenacting like
Nicolas Cage's character in leaving Las
Vegas yeah be more like you know what
I'm gonna go for a hike I'm gonna take
care of us that's not is it's not a sexy
and glamorous though you know I think a
lot of us I know Julia Cameron said
tortured artist get way more attention
and Pat's on the back then people that
are in it you know so I'm I wonder if we
kind of fall into this wanting to almost
be a tortured artist because he gets
more attention and people like you more
then if everything's great I hate this
person yeah man it's kind of a yeah it
happens it can definitely happen right
but it's kind of a [ __ ] narrative it
really is tell me and well you know like
you just said it's not as sexy and
glamorous and it's ironic because who's
sexy who sexified and glamorized it
that's sure right mm-hmm and so they you
know the same thing with with painters
you know van Gogh took his ear off right
nobody knew who he was thought he was a
bachelor crazy and now he's worshipped
in the door but he's not around for it
anymore
right so yeah I don't know you know I
mean it happens I understand it I don't
want to poopoo it it's tough
I've wrestled with it I still do you
know I'm not immune to it by any stretch
of the imagination but yeah man you got
to give yourself a break you got to do
the best you can and I I can't believe I
still work ha ha I look back at some my
old work and it's just I just you know
you cringe
I cringe like oh my god oh my god
right the imposter syndrome they say
they're gonna figure out one of these
days are gonna figure out you have no
idea what you're doing
everyone feels that way I've had the
good fortune of knowing dining with
being friendly with you know world
leaders and and and senators and federal
judges and civil rights leaders and and
they all have this similar everyone
across the board everyone
everyone feels like that you know and I
think it would be more helpful if we all
would hear that more often and realize
that more often and it's like okay man
yeah I feel like a fraud you know what I
you know I I feel yeah I think we can
probably see that my eye is twitching or
they can probably they can bra hear my
stomach gurgling or I should have had
that garlic last night or whatever it
may be and you just say f it I'm gonna
go ahead and do it anyway
what other BS narratives do you think
the industry instill I like it let's go
there listen all right I mean what else
do you think this you know there's sort
of the work hard put your head down do
better than the next guy it's not really
work anymore a hard work and discipline
right I used to hear those all the time
yeah you got to work obviously right as
you said earlier you're obsessed you
have the burning hot desire you're
driven to go get it you know you're
gonna work for that you're never not
going to go after that so that's a given
so then it's less about working hard and
keeping your head down and just you know
grinding it out it's ironic in this
business that's built upon creativity
that that's not I don't know what the
right word would be but that that's not
more fully fleshed out right it's not
necessarily about working harder because
if you're serious about it and you want
to be successful let's be honest let's
just be honest
everyone's in this town and in this
business because they want to make that
movie they want to make that series they
want to be that artist that director
that producer that writer right everyone
does and that's great right but you got
to acknowledge that your way is your way
right and it's not about working harder
it's about working smarter and it's not
about finding a tactic or technique or a
hack the new buzzword you know five
hacks to make your life go better it
sounds it sounds sexy and glamorous
right I just air quote
but you would be better served to be
strategic in your approach right because
the best strategy is going to crush the
best hacks techniques tips and tactics
every day all day there's a guy named
Sun Xue he wrote a little something
about it many centuries ago yeah
and Steven Pressfield did a another
thing the art of Steven Pressfield
wonderful yeah blew my mind when I read
those books so simple to make something
that's simple and that elegant and that
that deep do you struggle with
resistance yeah of course yeah every day
yeah when you find yourself in it how do
you get yourself out of it awareness so
I do everything I can to increase my
awareness and the thing that I found
that increases awareness more than
anything is meditation having talked
about before I was in that that cult and
I really did lose a 20-year span of my
life and in a large in a manner speaking
and also literally right because
psychologically the you know you're not
really thinking too clearly and I looked
and enacted normally everyone you know
people knew that something was up but I
still was functioning you know so you
know meditating is amazing meditation is
an amazing practice that's been around
for millennia right and it's just
becoming more popular in our culture
again now it hadn't been since the 60s
that's another conversation but that
that time has come again now I came
across when I was trying to to work my
way through this that that cult ordeal
this thing that was basically
high-technology meditation and I was
like what is that the long and the short
of it is with the press of a button on
your phone your mp3 player however you
choose to listen to it you can meditate
more deeply than a Buddhist monk who has
perfected their technique and been doing
it over thirty five years I was like huh
and
this gentleman had created this company
and he used this auditory Technic you
know called it this technology as
binaural beats anyway it puts you in
deep meditative state immediately and
it's amazing the biggest benefit of
meditation whether you choose to do it
that way or you do a traditional way is
that it begins to expand ones awareness
and with more awareness you have more
choice and you naturally notice that
that which doesn't serve you will just
kind of organically fall away so when
that resistance comes up I was talking
about what I'm focused on the meaning I
give something and the emotions that
come up I start to feel that resistance
I just kind of stop and this is this is
a hard-fought battle that I'm just
spitting out to you in a couple of
minute answer here was just to realize
that I was in a resistant place and
where that feeling was in my body and
then noticing where my breathing was and
then noticing where my focus was and
thinking about well why was this
happening why am I feeling that way with
oh that's right X happened I gave it Y
meaning and now I'm having Z feeling
this is kind of crazy huh no judgment no
criticism no critiquing at all just
noticing it with curiosity and this was
something that was recommended to me and
I thought when I first heard it man get
out of here there's resistance and I
didn't realize it and the person that I
was telling this to said oh really well
that's cool if you know it and and X Y Z
Y is your life still the way it is right
now and why are you suffering like all
right I don't like you any more I'm
going to talk to you and hung up but
it's the truth the more awareness I
developed and the more I started to pay
attention to what I was thinking about
how it was making me feel the meanings I
was assigned to things right and the
people in places that I was attracted to
and they were attracted to me everything
started to shift and change right
because as far as I can tell there's
only four things that any of us can
control and the rest
best we have influence so I can choose
what I focus on or what I think about
okay I can choose the meanings that I
assign to anything PS sidenote nothing
in and of itself has any inherent
meaning my head was blowing first on I
thought about that so those two things
the third thing is the feelings that I
have the emotions that I'm experiencing
those are all three under my control and
the fourth thing is kind of a / thing
the people I'm attracted to and the
people that are attracted to me those
are the only things I can control
anything else out of my control so if I
blow up an audition oh well right what
did I learn from it what could I have
done better am I being too harsh on
myself how do I even really know what
he/she they were thinking right maybe
they had the gasps face because they
just you know gotten some bad news or
you know chilli con carne went sour in
their stomach or who knows it could be
anything right instead of like just
beating yourself up and flogging
yourself you know any quick tip for
someone that's come out of a whether
they've been in a cult or whether
they've been they've just gotten newly
sober and maybe they were in a yeah
induced haze for years or they could
have been in a bad situation bad work
situation mm-hmm and kind of like coming
it cuz it's almost like you're coming
into life new again I would've met
almost like an infant
probably it's somewhere I'm I'm putting
words in your mouth no no no no no
that's that's interesting you said that
because yeah those thoughts came through
my head in the beginning as I was you
know start kind of wrapping my head
around this well first of all it's not
it's you know you got a as in this
industry so is it the same in recovering
from emotional trauma emotional abuse
occult alcoholism drug addiction sexual
abuse whatever horrible [ __ ] that goes
on in this world all the time whatever
it may be you got to play the long game
and that's easier said than done when
you're in the
throws of your pain and your suffering
right because there are times where
youth you know thoughts crossed my mind
to like is this worth it like is all
this worth it I always knew that life
was a gift and no matter how bad I felt
that I was gonna ride this thing out
maybe I'm delusional I don't know but
that was the choice I made but you look
at it the long game you're playing the
long game
it's not a tip it's not a trick it's not
a tactic it's not a technique it's not a
hack right you're doing a strategy and
you're healing yourself be nice to
yourself give yourself a break
make friends with yourself because no
matter where you go there you are and
the one like I said earlier the one
common in every relationship that you
have the one common denominator is me me
I'm the one so if that's the case and I
got to start taking responsibility for
everything I do
everything I say everything I think
right and then what's the thing that
they take back your power but you know
own it own yourself own your your stuff
even if it's painful even if it's ugly
just keep breathing and keep taking
another step I feel like a motivational
video but you know find your your your
creative outlets find your artistic
outlets find your athletic your your
physical outlets find spiritual outlets
whatever that means to you find you know
financial resources you know whatever it
may be but you know you've got you've
got to really the biggest thing I would
say is you got to be nice to yourself
you're doing the best you can do with
what you have at that time based upon
where you were and what you've been
through I know we're in what seems like
a freer culture right now where people
don't have to be bound by as much what
their own family of origin says they
should be doing and and people seem to
be okay with just kind of being who they
are it seems like we're coming into our
own like that and I know I this is I'm
just like doing a bunch of doublespeak
but let's talk about people that tell
you you they give you advice or not in
the industry and there's
telling you you shouldn't do that but
part of it might be because they
actually won't allow themselves to live
a life they want to live be with the
person they want to be with yeah choose
to go outside the sort of status quo of
of what their identity says they're
supposed to be the human condition baby
yeah right it happens all the time I
mean I'm sure that you both felt it
oh I've yeah but I've never been one to
care about like convention in fact I'm
might be more of an AMA
I'm kind of a natural yeah and I and
it's like I can't like a song everybody
likes right now and then I hear it the
years later I go actually that's pretty
good but because it was so popular at
that time I was cringed so I have that
disease I know that that is its own
affliction no it's the contrarian
complex I don't know what it is uh it
has to do with authority okay let's do a
thoraseal quickly just think about who
your primary authority figures were in
your life mom and dad and the
relationship you have with them that's
where it all stems from anyway yes they
do
so you know it takes courage to be an
artist takes an enormous courage to be
an artist whatever your your art is it's
not easy sitting down and pouring your
heart into a script right even if it is
a story you've created it's still your
blood sweat and tears right in your
heart on that page that takes guts sit
in front of a camera and act out those
words and perform it and bring it to
life with a point of view incredibly
hard but incredibly hard same for
directing same for the production same
for all of it it's all challenging so I
like I salute all artists because it
takes an enormous courage and that kind
of courage doesn't go unnoticed and when
people who aren't chasing their dream or
going after what they really want
whatever it may be doesn't necessarily
have to be in the arts right whatever it
may be when they aren't doing that and
they have fallen in step too
conventional
them to groupthink right and I know a
little bit about that because I got
caught up for that little group thing
that is extremely detrimental to one's
health and happiness and safety and yeah
jealousy comes out of that and so
condemnation it's the easiest thing in
the world right we'll all pick an attack
on each other constantly instead of
supporting each other and encouraging
each other and then you see that the
people who are the most successful in
any industry and any any walk of life
who are doing what they love love what
they're doing they're happier than more
peaceful and we're successful right
they're the most generous they're the
most supportive the most loving with
their time their resources their money
whatever it may be right because I think
they see and they understand inherently
how tough it is to put yourself out on
the line to put yourself out there let
yourself be seen warts and all right
yeah which is going back to you know we
all sit there and beat ourselves up oh
my god what were they thinking about it
was that terrible as that awful all
never work again right relax man
take it easy it's okay that's why I
think it's great you go out and find a
mentor someone who's you know succeeded
it doesn't even have to be in the same
thing you're doing in fact I really
encourage everyone to go out outside of
their comfort zone into completely
unknown territories and businesses and
industries and start to learn about them
if you have an interest in it not just
you know willy nilly a I'm gonna go into
the auto manufacturing you know plant
today you know if you're interested in
autos great but whatever it may be right
and just go put yourself out there go to
a workshop they have go to a seminar go
to a convention right go to a meeting
and and see what's going on and and
necessarily that starts to inform you
and on ways that you would never never
have expected really in the most
wonderful ways you know have you ever
had an audition where it went horrible
and then it turns out you got the part
ha ha ha and you were shocked like you
they didn't like you they didn't even
look up from there you know it's just
some story like that only if we count
every audition yeah no kidding
yeah that's happened that's happened
yeah quite a few times actually and that
is that's that's one of those times
where I stopped and thought to myself
son you don't know anything
you have got preconceived ideas you've
got presuppositions you're you're just
like man that's maybe you need to
rethink some things all right and and
that's a good thing that's a good thing
right
because it takes you outside of yourself
and that's not what everyone else is
doing right you can live your whole life
very comfortably doing what you're
supposed to do go to school get good
grades graduate get a job buy a house
get your mortgage have a family have
kids dah dah dah dah dah and that's all
wonderful but if it's not your thing
then it's not your thing and you need to
find out what your thing is and then go
and do that and doing that is going to
necessarily bring up what you're talking
about people judging you or people being
jealous of you or people trying to pull
you down or or people you know trying to
you know make it hard for you in any
number of ways you know usually it's
passive aggressiveness but you've got to
find that strength within yourself and
just keep soldiering on and fear um
because we we all here like these buzz
phrases but oh it's you know fears love
turn you know whatever the different
things are button right when you
actually see it happening and it could
be from people that you went to school
with that you were close in college
let's say or whatever and then you go on
a slightly different path and you see
their fear reaction yeah and it becomes
lonely because you say well do I comply
and stay with the group and now I have
somewhere to go yeah or do I do what I
want to do and then maybe the phone
stops ringing yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
crazy town right there yeah
but it can be the truth for a lot of
people whatever it could be for
entrepreneurs who want to start a
business and people say you're
absolutely don't leave that good job
great that's a great point so yeah that
that yeah that's how all that happens to
me it has happened happens a lot less to
me now but you know that's because I've
made a concerted effort to you know like
really keep myself more focused and more
aware of what I'm doing and what's going
on in any given situation that I am like
I said you know we're 'no screeds choice
the more awareness i have the more
choice i have and the more choice I have
I'm always going to naturally choose
what serves me in the situation better
you know so you know entrepreneurs and
artists are really kind of one of the
same thing because they all have the
same struggle you know you're creating
something from nothing whatever it may
be and you're gonna fail more often you
succeed that's that's just how it's
going to go and that requires a lot of
courage and you're gonna have to deal
with a lot of doubts and a lot of fears
and a lot of worries and a lot of
resentments and jealousies and and and
and and you have to find your way
through that because there is no one way
and anyone tries to tell you oh well
this is the way you do it is either
lying to you bullshitting you or trying
to sell you something really simple
right all three or all three at the same
time which is an especially distasteful
combination so be nice to yourself man
find out what works for you and you're
gonna find out what works for you by
finding out what doesn't work for you
constantly fear everyone has it you know
Brene brown became very you know popular
with her TED talk and then you know her
appearances on national television I
think it's genius in its simplicity and
it's it's you know showing your
vulnerability you know look I don't have
the answers I certainly don't in fact
the more I learned the more I know I
don't know anything and the grand scheme
of things
who the hell am i when you show yourself
right when you put yourself out there
when you let yourself be seen your words
your artwork your direction whatever it
may be your music your lyrics whenever
it is your dancing your your body your
hair your everything that's necessarily
a vulnerable place but that's where all
the magic happens right letting people
come in and see you and feel your
humanity right and see it for all of its
flaws because we all have those flaws we
all do and in this industry it's really
easy to put forth an image and have a
narrative and then get that thing
stamped boom boom boom boom and you show
up across all these you know television
shows and all these radio interviews and
all these podcasts and you know or you
know you're very pensive or whatever it
may be but that's not the whole picture
it never is right it's just what's in
the frame and what's in the frames
what's in the frame but that's not the
whole story right so don't be afraid to
let someone know you don't know what's
going on or you know what yeah I'm
scared man I don't know how this is
gonna go that happens and you know I go
and do a scene and it's a very emotional
scene or it's a very dangerous scene or
a very physical scene god I hope this
goes well
all right but you know I've done my work
I've made strong choices and I know what
the story being told is and I know
what's going on and then I got to just
trust the other actor with me I got to
trust the writing the words on the page
and the setting and the dynamic and just
go let it happen right similarly I think
it would be really well it would be
great advice and great thing to start to
add that into your life as well kind of
coming back full circle art saved my
life I learned that through art five
things and actors should not do in the
audition room oh wow five things an
actor's not doing the audition room the
worst thing an actor can do is to
have the smell of desperation on them
neediness and desperation it is death
it's an estimate to what you want to
have happen and that is that I forget
five that's the two things right there
if you go and put so much importance on
an audition I gotta have this like right
and most of like what most actors are
broke most of the time right especially
when you're starting out sleeping on I
know I was sleeping on the floor in a
one-bedroom apartment sleeping on the
floor my right hand to God so you know
you need the job and you know you just
you put everything on it so you walk in
you're needy you're desperate hope they
like me man nobody wants to work with
that nobody wants to work with that
that's death you know so you've got to
do everything in your power to to keep
that from happening even if you need
that job like you need oxygen right that
would tell you if you kind of pull back
and look at it you need to start finding
other streams of revenue right if you
have to get a side job right day job
whatever they want to call it
maybe day jobs not the thing to do
especially in today's day and age you
can drive your damn car
crazy to me but you can do it right I
don't mean it's crazy to do it's like
what an amazing thing to be right now I
wish I had that option
wow that's pretty very clear now is it
boy so that would be the first thing and
I think the biggest thing to answer that
question would for it would be for an
actor to get on the other side of the
table so you sit on the casting side of
the table and watch the actors come
through nothing will inform you quite so
rapidly as to every mistake that you
make hmm that's interesting yeah like
you're gonna do your work you're gonna
make your choices hopefully we all do it
and most actors don't prepare enough in
the beginning they learn but you know I
don't think that's this crowd and even
this would go for writers too when
you're taking a meeting you know you got
to you got to do your work you got to
get prepared make your choices know what
you're gonna talk about have your pitch
but if you're desperate
yeah no one wants to be around
they want to be running someone who's
fun to be around someone who's prepared
who's professional who they can rely
upon it was responsible and fun
hopefully fun and if you're funny bonus
not that that's important but you know
it's a job it's a job interview have
there been times when you have felt
desperate and you feel like you might
have that was the reason that it didn't
go well that's how I learned
Hellyeah fixed well then I first started
I go for an audition yeah the auditions
didn't come very often so when you had
the audition when I had an audition I
would think to myself oh my god I got to
get this I got to get this I got to get
this because I'm really competitive and
driven and you know an ambitious those
aren't dirty words by the way some
people think they I just gonna have to
bleep out a competitive I'm sorry
seriously oh I'm kidding amazing
yeah it's that that's that's not okay on
film Kurt sorry duly noted so so I would
you know I was desperate as they came I
wanted that job to succeed to save yes
look what I have done right and the
other part of it excuse me was because I
just I'm gonna be a star right and then
the beginning was like doing a 5 and
under you know they play a role had no
idea what any of it meant I didn't get
the broader context of it so you walk in
I walk in and I would be desperate or
I'd be needy or I'd be who knows who
knows any number of things but yeah
definitely I did and I learned started
to learn like oh my god that's not good
don't want to do that then and for me it
did happen when I got on the other side
and and watched the casting process
happen and you can tell right away you
know so when there were times let's say
when other things were going on maybe
you added several projects and then you
just happen to pop in for another one or
something and then that sort of I don't
want to call it breeziness because
that's the wrong word but the not
needing it so badly ended up you getting
another one because they're like oh I
like to
guy did that happen you're asking man
yeah absolutely right because they're
there again managing your well I wasn't
even think about managing your emotions
but you're not desperate you're not
needy you've got a job you're feeling
good about yourself and look let's be
honest and into this business there's so
many ups and downs like that's not a
consistent you know unless you're really
lucky you have your own show you're part
of an ensemble show you're you know
movie star whatever it may be and and
you know you're gonna be working for X
number of days are you gonna be working
for X number of months that's a
different situation for everyone else
which is literally 98% of the acting
industry right it's this all the time
right so if you are working and you get
a chance to go in audition in between
that man you just feel like you're on
top of the world desperation and
neediness or nowhere to be found
you've already you're you know you're up
here with it but instead of looking at
it like yeah my you know doesn't stink
because I'm working and yeah yeah you
know it starts posturing and fronting
like you're like slow your own take it
easy I'm happy for you I never say that
of course never say that but you know
look at that and see what that is what
is that what's going on watch cuz I'm
not I don't need this I don't feel like
I need this yeah I want it sure I'm
gonna do my best job but you know I'm
more loose I'm more free and you know
improvisation for everyone I think is
one of the most informative important
things you could ever do you know
whether you're acting writing directing
whatever it's really smart you know a
little side note there's a guy I know
really smart guy
and he was going to get into his
father's business father did very well
in this industry and won tons of awards
and really really powerful and great
talented person and son wanted to do the
same thing and he said well you know if
you want to you know direct and write
and produce you've got to know what
acting
you got to know how to talk to the
actors and and I see that happen so
frequently where directors they don't
understand the process they don't know
what's going on and they're just like
what is you know that you want to stay
away from the actor or they'll they will
not necessarily demonize isn't the right
word but kind of categorize the actor as
difficult crazy stupid whatever right
and so he told his son that you need to
go take acting classes and I was like
what he doesn't need acting classes he's
not gonna act but it wasn't about that
it was about understanding the actors
process the craft the skill and
everything else and you know he knew he
was gonna be an actor but he sat in
there it was like I don't know a six
week course and showed up every class
you know got up on stage you know doing
all the work and yeah one of the
smartest things he ever did you know and
he's not doing that at all now I think
that's smart you know you should learn
all those things because especially in
today's business you know Rome is
burning right in front of us all right
commercials have disappeared which is
how most actors made a living in between
like a real you know put your teeth into
a role whether it be in television or
film or whatever get your residuals you
get your pension benefits you get your
health care kind of important right yeah
that's pretty much disappeared and now
everything has become another thing
altogether right non-union jobs etc but
you know you if you're just going to say
well I'm just going to be an actor I'm
just gonna be a writer I'm just to be a
director I'm just going to do this I
think that that's probably not the most
resourceful way to go about things it
would be better if you were a
conglomeration of everything and and
truthfully if again if we're gonna be
honest you know everyone wants to make a
mark wants to you know say something so
maybe creating your own thing is the
smartest thing to do
like I'd mentioned before this
transmedia model of the business these
days is really brilliant and it's
because it brings in like all aspects of
where the industry is currently and
where it's going in the future
and it also looks at it from a business
perspective financially in the most
intelligent way that I've seen I'm not
the de facto you know Oracle to talk on
that but it makes a lot more sense than
the way people approach things currently
because usually they'll write a script
you sell it you know it's a one-and-done
so to speak or maybe you're fortunate
and the movie does really well or this
series does really well and but then you
know you're back on that you know what's
your next thing going to be right
transmedia doesn't do that you have that
one super story right and then you have
kind of like your soapbox your message
that is the through line with everything
that comes out of your super story and
then that story is told over a variety
of media right and it's not the same
story so you can explore characters you
can explore location you do it via
podcasts maybe a guided tour maybe apps
that you know further take the story
down another path of the movie or the
television series or the documentary or
whatever it may be wasn't able to fully
explain because of the parameters of
that part of the story and then you know
you take something like that you flush
all that out you take something like
that to an investor now you're not just
a writer or a director or an actor or an
artist or a Hollywood type coming to ask
someone to invest in your movie singular
product and by the way most movies are
losing financial propositions and there
are a number of reasons for that right a
number of reasons for that and the least
of which has to do with your talent or
your skill set but it does have to do
with your skill set in the arena of
business so now if you come to someone
transmedia model and you show them what
you've got and you explain to it how
you're going to you know distribute this
and how it's going to be rolled out and
what what the plan is for it and then
you have the numbers to back up the
financial aspect of what you're asking
for and what the return on that
investment would be now you're talking
dollars and cents now you're talking
Studios are like oh okay now you've got
the studio person's full attention
you've got the network person's full
attention you've got the investment
bankers full attention
alright and this stuff never gets talked
about well I won't say never that's not
right but it doesn't get talked about
often enough and certainly not in a way
that would be more helpful to people
because you know if you're gonna create
something you're gonna go to all that
effort you know you want it to be seen
you know Houston Howard talks about the
phenomenon of art like if no one really
experiences it then you know what was it
and forgive me I'm butchering it but you
want it to be seen so you have to have a
distribution model and then beyond that
you have to have a back-end there's a
sail there's the first sail in business
you have your sail and most sails are
either breakeven and many times it's a
loss leader so it cost me you know $5 to
make my widget and I'm selling it to you
for $3 so I'm losing on it right but
what I've done is I've gained a customer
and it's not in the first sale you make
your money you make your money on every
subsequent sale on the back end as they
say and and that's taken into place
that's taken in consideration in the
transmedia model which I mean it's
brilliant it's not that it hasn't been
before but it's smart it's really smart
if you were going to take a movie like
Forrest Gump yes and apply a transmedia
model to it how would you do it so
Forrest Gump right movie I love great
movie heartstring movie right so I mean
I didn't write it so but you look at it
I mean everyone says life's like a box
of chocolates let's just say that's this
this the kind of the message the the
thematic the the soapbox of it right and
that the the broader super story is that
no matter what the obstacle is in your
life right it doesn't have to be the
defining aspect of your life okay
and so you could spin those you could
spend that message off in a number of
ways you could take that message and say
like you know you could you could
Forrest was mentally challenged right so
you could do a documentary about people
like Forrest right there's one thing
right there you could create a podcast
about the town I forget what it was in
Alabama I forget right now
you could do the podcast about that town
in the various locations in that town
interesting now talking about Forrest
Gump you know talking about Forrest
write something Bo Alabama just came to
me doesn't okay it'll come but anyway
that's another thing you could create a
board game about the invention of the
brace that forst's wore as a child this
is the transmedia model incidentally
today's like today the kids of today and
that's the market place right those are
the people to go and see stuff they
don't even watch television no no
television really is for all intents and
purposes they get they get a starstruck
by YouTube character channel creator
whatever as they as we did looking at
you know oh my god it's who did you go
oh my god over oh I want to be Brooke
Shields a little girl and I was just
look at all the teen magazines and go I
want to be her absolutely right exactly
that doesn't happen anymore today they
go nuts over the YouTube thing and
everything's in smaller kind of
bite-sized content is the buzzer I kind
of hate that word but we'll just go with
it let's see that's not to bleep that
out that's yeah that's the contrarian in
me but Jeffrey Katzenberg and his
partner oh god I forgot who it is right
now they've created a new company and
they've invested a lot of money into it
and it's all videos that are 5 minutes
and less or six minutes and less
interesting all right so that's a whole
other transmedia model you could you
could take little five six minutes
stories it's not the whole story it's
just parts of it that further enrich it
because what you want to do is you want
to build a brand a franchise with raving
fans right you want to build something
you want to create something along the
lines of George Lucas is done with Star
Wars JK Rowling did with Harry Potter
what Steve Jobs did with Apple for God's
sake is there really anything that
magnificent about Apple computers not
really no well the two Steve's were
interesting in their own right so I
think people wanted to know about them
as well Wozniak in jobs Yeah right that
dynamic right yeah there was they
weren't interesting but did that have
anything to do with the nuts and bolts
of that computer no but it made the
company more interesting you know but
but do you think and I hate to just I
just want to challenge this idea for
Louise do it's great to think about
building an audience yeah is it really
that easy now in when we're shooting
this 2019 back when you know YouTube was
starting was it 2005 or whatever yes so
okay that was one time but it's gotten
much it's just a different animal now do
you how easy is it to really build an
audience well nothing's easy nothing's
easy right and nothing worthwhile is
easy at all if it were everyone would be
doing it however at our disposal are any
number of ways to build an audience that
we're not available before it's kind of
mind-blowing that you know with your
smartphone with your laptop you know you
can start to build a fan base you can
start to capture email addresses you can
start to create content you can start to
there's another way you know your you
could create a blog that's another thing
these these all are ways of reaching out
telling your story and gathering the
information and gathering fans interest
in your project right because you know
you you write this incredible that most
talented most beautifully written thing
in the world
right or the most an unbelievably acted
piece of work that had ever been done if
there's not an audience for it no studio
or network is gonna invest in it because
right they want to return on their
investment well if we took forrest gump
sure and that was 94 was it yeah I think
so yeah I was like four at that time
okay hundred years old I don't look bad
for over 500 right yeah thank you I
think the prehistoric ears were good to
you i but if we took Forrest Gump in
today's today's landscape yeah it
probably wouldn't have had the same
appeal because there's so many things
competing at that time in 94 there was
Nirvana and whatever I don't know what
month Forrest Gump came out but there
were there was a grunge there were
different things but it wasn't we
weren't competing for so many things
yeah there were video games but it
wasn't not on the level it is you have
that many things vying for your
attention
sure that's right and we didn't have
these little addiction devices right
away
sidenote we're all addicts we Ric I go
through I see people of all walks of
life homeless whatever with with cell
phones and they are into it yeah there
was interesting I saw a woman a homeless
woman asking a young girl for advice on
how to fix her phone and they were
fixing it together and I was like how
that's really fabulous pretty cool and
and the girl like knew like exactly what
to do and anyway that's that's a side
note but that shows you where we are you
know and this was in a park and the
woman's on a bench and she had a
question and the girl helped her and so
anyway I'm getting sidetracked I love
this so building an audience it's catchy
how possible is it today what's not
catchy it's imperative it's imperative
and you know you can't compare 1994 to
now it's not fair why cuz you just can't
you can't and and that but that's a
common pushback whenever I talk about
this and this is you know this is
nothing
new I didn't create this or anything
it's a common push back oh you know name
a director didn't have to do that right
yeah you're right they didn't but that
was then and this is now that's true
right and so if you continue to do
things that worked back then and you're
doing those things now and you're
wondering why you're not getting a
similar result maybe change your
approach so yeah it's not catchy to
build an audience it's imperative to
build an audience and everything should
be done with that and in mine but I also
think that not but I will say and I
think that looking at it in a financial
aspect that makes sense to have people
want to invest in your project that's
also imperative you know because
otherwise you're looking at writing
something one time right acting in
something one time and hoping against
hope that it does well right come on
lucky seven right right and in a large
extent that is kind of we're all
gambling in this industry right but
doesn't that make more sense than
instead of your gambling that you oh god
I hope this works out right I hope this
works out that you have a strategy in
place that no matter what happens here
it's supported hear hear hear hear hear
hear hear hear
and by the way each one of those is a
revenue stream so how does an actor
incorporate transmedia into their brand
which is they themselves so I'm clearly
not looking at this like an actor right
I mean that's I've kind of stepped out
of the acting realm now I'm really in
the producer writer business room
majorly
right but if they're all tied together
so I don't know how to so sorry I don't
know how to answer that question I have
certainly not come across any actors
that are even thinking like this I don't
know how to answer that but I think it's
smart to do it
because I dunno I can say this you know
there are lots of stories of actors who
created their own vehicle and Billy Bob
Thornton created Slingblade we all know
what happened there and we can on and on
and on and on I mean even Howard Stern
for God's sake not even an actor but you
know there's a guy who understands you
know media calls himself the king of all
me yeah right
smart makes that crazy movie has is
basically his radio is his radio program
now he's on you know call it a podcast
it's on Sirius Radio signed a deal for
five hundred million dollars right so
look at that think about that how can
you apply that to your thing because if
you're gonna sit back as an actor and
wait for the audition the role that one
that's gonna make it for you man you
know you could get older than me and and
it never happens 500 years old and it
just makes more sense that you would put
your energy and focus into something
that makes sense in today's world makes
sense in today's entertainment world you
know Jeff Katzenberg head of DreamWorks
and his partner now are making
six-minute videos and they've got a
whole bunch of money behind it and
they're I guarantee you mr. Katzenberg
doesn't invest money to lose it right so
that's something I'd pay attention to as
an actor as a writer as a director as a
producer what's going on there let me
investigate that even if I have no idea
what I'm doing
dive in think bigger man think bigger
yeah it was interesting to go into the
library and see posters on the wall for
like sign up for our youtuber class to
become a youtuber and then there's Jake
Paul's book like featured it's just
fascinating because you're right Gen
Xers and and and whatever we were used
to looking at whoever our favorite
celebrity was I'm thinking how do I
become like that or how do I you know
sort of get around that but that was a
different world that was where there
were you know it was just it I don't
want to use the word gatekeeper it's
been
okay it's it's another word I want to
bleep out so but there were quote
gatekeepers up there and and now it's
different and now the it's not the
gatekeepers it's how do you compete with
eyeballs and so that is very difficult
that's a new dilemma it's not now
getting passed and getting your headshot
into the to the proverbial pizza box and
and and trying to deliver it it I don't
know if anybody ever really did that but
it was a great sounds great yeah being a
singing telegram I'm really dating
myself with that one but and and and
then oh hey here's my head shot you know
that but how do you compete with
eyeballs so great yeah now the power is
in everybody's hands to create something
but now you're competing with a
gazillion things true and that is the
new dilemma okay so that that is true
and that's also not completely accurate
so if we think about that you're not
creating with all of that because you
are not you know in business if you try
to be all things to everybody we dead in
the water
alright alright so you're talking about
a brand yourself right or your project
branding it okay well then you have to
figure out what your message is who's
going to resonate with that you know
that in the marketing world they call
that your avatar you know who is the
person you're talking you think about
one person like oh my person is Lisa and
Lisa is a 35 year old mother of two
girls and she has a pitbull she's very
dainty she likes to wear very light kind
of what's the what's the word I can't
think of the pastel colors but yes she
has this pitbull with an attitude right
but see how specific I'm getting so
that's what we're going to instead of
going oh I've got a gazillion eyeballs
cool let's just bring it down let's
bring that focus even tighter right just
like you're doing a camera shot you
don't have the whole room we're in right
right yeah and that way now now you've
got this from this big unyielding thing
down to something that's much more
manageable so you can be more focused
more specific your choices are stronger
your directions
I mean that's that's just that's how I
would approach it that's how you know
that would be the smarter way to
approach it I believe so maybe I'm wrong
sorry
is the actor finding their one Lisa
casting director is that who their man I
don't know that that's you know I'll
tell you what most actors will not tell
you what they did to succeed to get
their success because I remember when I
started out man I could just talk to it
someone who knows this business and can
tell me you know how they got where they
got what they did right not that I'm
gonna do exactly that
but it would give me a more clear
picture and understand the the workings
the dynamics at play the you know maybe
some of the personalities maybe some of
the relationships right that would be
really helpful what I found out is most
people don't know how they got where
they got they just got lucky right they
don't really think about it I think
that's fair to you know most people
don't think about oh I just did the you
know you hear the the thing that you
said earlier you know keep your head
down just work hard and you know be a
good person and like okay man great you
know I was more interested in the
strategy like what is the strategy how
do you get from A to Z right go back to
the Steve's with Apple so what did he do
to make his computer be more desirable
than others right so he took it from all
these eyeballs and by the way everyone
was using the PC it's still the dominant
computer oh right the dominant well I
think Apple has 10% market share maybe
mas o menos I don't know so what he did
was he took his design and his
salesmanship and started to craft and
create a message right think different
think differently for the writers out
there which is grammatically correct to
think different then he had that
infamous you know 1984's commercial that
he did but boy did it move people right
and then he had some successes and
failures and then ultimately what one
Apple really took off was when he turned
it
to the iMac and brought it out and you
know five fruity flavors you know all
the colors right who I want the blue one
who I want the pink one right and
everything changed so right everything
changed he created the eye the iMac
that's what it was called right and then
after that I think came out the iPod
when people started making jokes the
iMac the iPod the Iraq the I Ronal the
things right but he had a strategy in
place because the iMac was supported and
supported the iPod and they were both
going to be supported by iTunes
he had a framework in place right so he
gets you with one thing but then he's
going to keep getting you on the back
end with things
boom boom boom take that same strategy
and apply it to your career wherever you
are whatever your discipline is whatever
your art is I think that's just a
smarter way to approach things right
clearly it's more business oriented but
again it is called show business right
and it would behoove all of us to think
more about the business aspect of it you
certainly have to know your craft you
certainly have to have a strong
viewpoint you certainly have to have
your voice developed but you don't mean
a thing if it ain't got that business to
it why do you think people take advice
from non-working professionals in the
industry ha why do they I don't know I
think that's another big question but
that's not smart to take advice from
someone who's not you know doing well in
whatever it is they're doing if it maybe
you know there's always temporary
setbacks and there's lulls there's abs
and flows but I mean to take acting
career advice or to take writing advice
from a banker it's an interesting choice
I don't know that that's the most
resourceful choice to take acting advice
from
your mother who is you know a clinical
psychologist maybe a little more
resourceful but I don't know if that's
the best choice at all because you know
you you would make more sense to take
advice from someone who's doing it and
succeeding at it no matter what it you
know what level it's at you know maybe
you know you've pushed back and I hear
that a lot when I talk about you know
transmedia and business and money well I
just want to create cool stuff so do i
man so do i right I also want to be
compensated for it really really cool
compensation right like more than like a
bowl of soup and a hat so I don't know
why people do that but that especially
the actors that happens a lot a lot I
suppose it happens I mean that's not
fair it probably happens to everyone
in this business more often than it
doesn't and I think it's just where
you're you know reaching you're grasping
at straws you just anyone somebody you
know you get asked to play roles where
you have an accent British accent
Australian that's so interesting I have
a facility for accents and I guess
characters I used to sit as a kid and
watch TV foot drive my family crazy and
then as I got better than they would
laugh and they enjoyed it but I was just
mimic the voices I was hearing I don't
know why I did it I just did it you know
and I would just try to find the
placement of the voice and the breathing
pattern and how they hold their body and
whatever I didn't know what the hell I
was doing I was just doing it I have not
done any I've done one character with an
accent and I don't think I did a very
good job with it but I did it
and again accents yeah I'd love to do it
not just for this just to do the accent
you know hasn't speaking as an actor you
know if that's what the character
requires if that's who the character is
if it's you know if it serves the story
of course otherwise you know it just
becomes like you know hey did you hear
my cool accent
huh huh how about that accent huh
sounded like I was straight out of West
Texas right yeah okay I was actually I
was thinking your George Bush accent and
I was like no don't say no George George
Bush is so George Bush yeah
George Bush greatest George Bush word
ever strategic oh we honest to god I'm
the decider
and strategic love that what's the
hardest accent you've ever had to learn
the hardest accent I ever had to learn
I'm an American accent how is that how
is that different from I mean like what
well I start cadence is like what well
first of all English is an extremely
difficult language to learn Farsi was my
first language yeah I was born in Iran
in Tehran so I mean I came to this to
the state's when I was 2 but I you know
started to speak and you know it was you
know two-year-olds talk they can SPRO
yeah yeah so but you know you're a kid
you don't think about it you don't beat
yourself up you give yourself a break
you don't even worry about what other
people think about you right and I'm not
suggesting that we all become children
again
okay and to go children
but yeah the hardest accent you know
what's really tough if to try to speak
actually to speak the language would be
for me would be Chinese would be Korean
would be Vietnamese and Japanese and I'm
probably missing several other languages
but those are the ones that are most top
of my mind right now
when I hear Vietnamese being spoken just
a simple inflection in the way you say
the word changes the entire meaning of
the word how interesting oh yeah oh yeah
I asked a friend of mine about that how
long do you think would take just to
speak taking me to speak of yet nummies
if I started to apply myself that it was
all take you forever
hey just any and this is a guy a friend
of my wife and I he's I got a PhD in
mathematics and he's an artist he
created this incredible virtual reality
piece based around four
Obama's election and and that's a whole
thing but it's it's really cool but
anyway his name is coin when and he just
like very just casually said something
issues work we were working as oh forget
it
take you forever difficult difficult it
was like wow okay thanks for the vote of
support there but that that those would
be tough those are tough Farsi is very
tough for the American here you know to
sounds they have K in the day right they
that just not just Americans like what
you say what right yeah can you explain
that
yeah can you explain that can you say
that in American yeah
what are you from they worse you from I
get that a lot yeah I get that a whole
lot
well you have a great look because you
could be so many things but you could
definitely play out out of West Texas
absolutely and so we could yeah do do
you have different looks on your on your
you know just for your website and
different things where you just try to
play it more Anglo or whatever or plot
try to be more Mediterranean that's a
great question
you know I have necessarily played
different characters who looked at
different way but in coming back to you
know you don't want to work and you want
to be successful and you want to
continue that path what ended up being
my bread and butter were I call it suit
man because I this this is new the hair
and not sure thing having a beer well
thank you women love it guys not so much
okay it's interesting it's been a very
interesting the past couple of years now
I've grown my hair out to see the
reaction and stuff and and it's kind of
been I say this a you know like it's a
career suicide am I out of my effing
mind to do this because I was always
clean shaven short hair I looked at
pictures of myself I'm like oh my god
who is that who is that guy but that guy
worked all the time but it was a look
right mr. Morgan Stanley I mean totally
no I do horseman no no no I did a lot of
financial institution ass I did a lot of
billionaires yeah I can see that
technological you know luminary kind of
people doctors lawyers like these
authority figure people right and I
guess it's kind of my voice and my
energy and whatever got a dance with who
brung you right but there's a whole
other a splicing lease a you know people
haven't seen me in a while like oh wow
your hair
Mike yeah man this is who I am on the
inside I just let it come out yeah right
cuz it was funny thing what happened to
me on sets you know I'd be on a set I
have this you know hair like comb back
and you know very clean-cut you know
probably racist definitely conservative
definitely you know whatever gotta have
fun with it and then I would start
talking about the things that I'm doing
later that week and people just kind of
go huh yeah they're like you know you
you don't talk anything like the way you
look and that sounds so obvious when you
hear it but I would just wouldn't think
about it because I got a job at hand I'd
go back and do the job and that'd be a
craft service table or it would be you
know on set between takes or whatever
and then later at night at home I will
usually at night you're laying in bed
like what what does that mean but it and
now I go back and look at the pictures
of myself I'm like oh my god yeah you
know okay that makes sense I wouldn't
expect that guy to talk like that either
yeah you know just a saying in this
business I stay sane but it's something
that's important to me and it was part
of you know recovering from being
undermined control for all those years
and in a cult which is really just an
abusive relationship in a lot of ways
it's a lot more than that but that's
really what it is
so being of service to others who are
not as fortunate than me so just by the
nature of me having this white skin
right I have got an easier path in life
I just do and I'm a man and I'm a tall
man and you're very attractive
oh well thank you very much well that
that so those are things going in my
favor that I had nothing to do with that
was just the genetic lottery right
that's just the roll of dice so you know
I'm married to a woman who's a black
woman and grew up in a very unique
situation civil rights movement my
father-in-law and his best friend
started the civil rights movement so it
gave me a whole other perspective that I
never looked at before in life ever and
I feel like in a heel for not noticing
it because in my family so my father's
Iranian my mother's American whether
both Americans but you know he came from
Iran and they had four boys first of all
they eloped to get married oh wow my
mother still wants to fight me on that
that she didn't elope but I don't know
you tell me if you get married okay and
neither family is excited
the marriage okay like his family had a
wife picked out for him oh right and he
was raised Muslim can't stand religion
right thinks it's the scourge of the
earth my mother was raised as a Mormon
exactly she didn't want to exact what a
family dinner that would be hang on
there's more but wait there's more so
they got married in Reno Nevada
on December 31st with none of the family
members there that's eloping am I wrong
I would imagine I would imagine what's
right right yeah those little chapels
and reaaargh I've been to Reno they have
some really interesting like these it's
a gambling yeah yeah it's Nevada right
you know in Vegas right so they were in
Reno because they were living in San
Francisco at the time or he was going to
school up there something like that
anyway they have four boys I'm the
oldest of four boys all three of my
brothers were gay right I'm the black
sheep amazing right and then on top of
that we moved a lot like every two and a
half three years was the new kid again
new guy with this really long Iranian
name like it's a proper Iranian name but
I look like Steve apple pie right that
and so how conflicting yeah and my last
name is beech Archie right Dixon is my
middle name
my full first name is DAR you summed are
you sure Dixon beech Archie there's a
mouthful but then I look like this so
there's a huge disconnect cognitive
dissonance every time a new kid and by
the way a B C D sighs either the first
or second kid called every time how oh
gosh awesome and you're the new guy and
it's a funny name so there was always
that conversation right yeah yeah it's a
whole thing
it's the whole thing how do you
reconcile that being from sort of two
different worlds and maybe not even
identifying with either one just like I
don't know I'm assuming yeah no you man
you hit the nail on the head
it's a lot it's so part of it is just
that's that's my life that's how I was
raised
that was the cert those were the
circumstances of me of my life and then
as I've gotten older I start to realize
wow that's a lot that's a lot right like
your reaction just now three gay
brothers yeah three gay brother not one
three right out of four right [ __ ] in
a Mormon
Iranian an American right I had to elope
even though mom doesn't like that sorry
mom
it is a lot and then on top of that Iran
became the axis of evil sure
it's the ISIS in the eyes of a lot
Americans of America right which is a
whole other conversation I have by the
way for another time and then America by
the Iranians is called the Great Satan
and my friend Cyrus Copeland wrote a
great book about his father and we knew
each other growing up in Iran and it's a
great book off the radar I highly
recommend it but he says you know I have
the blood of the Great Satan and the
axis of evil flowing through my veins
and I was started in the laughs I
couldn't stop laughing and I was like
dude you hit the nail on the head it's
kind of bananas and then but you know I
live in America I've lived most of my
life in this country you know all but
about five and a half years have been in
this country and I love you Ron I love
you Ron and not all Iranians hate
Americans by the way no they don't yeah
that's okay yeah that's something that
our media has definitely helped to
portray sorry well yeah no it's if they
don't and you know when my friend went
to when Cyrus went to Iran he was doing
research on the book he had an
interaction or he burned his foot in the
sauna sauna I think so he went to see
the doctor at this hotel that he was
staying at and and he's like oh you know
your bandaging you know the leg of the
Great Satan and and the doctor says uh
look
there's a big difference between your
government and your people just is it a
big difference between my government and
my people and right now I'm treating a
person and you're talking to a person
and the government doesn't have anything
to do with this right yeah and that's a
wisdom that that's not just that that's
a very common place in Iran which is one
of the most educated populations in the
entire Middle East certainly in the
world they put up they place a premium
on education and they're one of the
oldest civilizations in our planet right
and there's a wisdom to that comment
like the government is the government
the people are the people and there are
two separate beings the government can
be saying one thing but the people have
a different feeling altogether so yeah
it's it's interesting it's it's it's
been challenging because since 1977 when
the rope or 79 when the revolution
occurred the Iranian Revolution which we
you know we escaped luckily by I mean
had the clothes on her back in suitcases
that was it it was it was not fun but we
got off a lot easier than a lot of
families did but since that time man you
know as soon as people find out I have
Iranian blood you know things go
sideways you know and it's always very
small it's just you know but it goes
sideways you can see it in people's
faces you can hear in their voice you
can see in their body language and you
know inside they get upset that's okay
thinking of a book by Flannery O'Connor
and she wrote a lot about you know
racism in the south and she talked to
you that there was one line where she
said like I feel sorry for people that
are half because they have it the
hardest because I'm actually she was
reading it so I'm like imitating her
voice and that that is very difficult
when you are in you you're not a whole
of something in terms of being accepted
by both by by one side or another and I
think that's very difficult for people
when they're a mixture of something in
that sense I know we're all mixtures of
something but because you're never it's
almost like you're not part of
the one side totally I don't know I'm
thinking of my own experience yeah I
don't you know it's it's it's
everybody's got their something right
like this is definitely you know again
I'm a white man in America and a first
world you know first world country white
man and I've got money in the bank I got
food in the fridge and a roof over my
head so what am I talking about
however you know the emotional world is
a different thing and then having to
deal with you know the social aspect the
fabric of wherever I am yeah it's you
know I said I got choked up I stopped
you stopped it it does me and it bothers
me it wears me up and it gets and I'm
white imagine if I had darker skin right
or maybe an even bigger nose or thicker
lips or nappy hair right I don't know
then what right so I in a lot of ways
what do I owe a my to talk I can only
speak about my experience and hmm I
don't know that's a big question that's
it's that's a lot says a lot
I do feel Iranian and in so many ways
was my first language my first sounds
the first music the first smells the
first food you know the first sites were
necessarily all in Iran they're all
Persian it's all that right and that's
deep deep deep inside me I remember when
we went to live in Iran I was about 12
years old and we went back and it was
like going back to a very familiar place
I'll necessarily call it home because
you know I was a kid and I thought
America was that's all I really knew
consciously but it was like the sound
the rhythm the cadence the smells the
the beat you know the groove of the
whole thing was all very familiar which
was wonderful
yeah really wonderful in ways that I
can't really fully explain
and you don't get cast as an Iranian I
imagine I don't see it in you at all
never I see a guy that gave you from the
San Diego yeah like this they think I
would go your Beach guy your surfer
right but I've also seen photos of you
from from doing the research and you
could be yeah the Morgan Stanley you
know guy that's on the 18th floor and is
with the steeple you know hands and you
know guy guy on speakerphone and it's
like you know I did a lot of roles like
that a whole lot yeah yeah and it's
always the most fun you get to be the
obnoxious you know like the [ __ ] sure
that's just come on where else can you
act like that and get paid for it and
not get a rest and have people hate you
because they know you're just playing a
part right but that must be interesting
to reconcile with that because then
you're also playing a role in that sense
that maybe fearful of actually who you
really are or where you came from
oh yes like a weird thing I'm sure yeah
yeah yeah I've had to yeah I've had to
go that'd be that guy that you know the
short hair that you know steeple hands
the you know master of the universe mr.
suit man as I called it and had to say
some ugly words and act you know less
than favourably toward other people and
say some really some ideologies that I
don't share at all and you know it's I
can jump into that and do it easily
because I've heard it come at me and
I've heard it come at you know my loved
ones more often than I care to mention
but yeah it's it's a weird one you know
yeah Here I am I've got this hair
growing out and I'm not playing suit men
anymore and I'm talking about trans and
media put it right and creating this
something you know a whole different
thing like a franchise type of a thing
which is like it's crazy big thinking
but you know what why not why not
because that guy I feel like that guy's
been played out he can always come back
man you can cut hair shave and
throw a suit and tie on and you know
he's back you know you can do a ponytail
and slick it and then just you could
study that I've done that too yeah I
could still be that guy with a ponytail
you can do all of these still exists but
you know the funny thing is as I go into
casting offices for the past
I don't know how ever long a year now
and someone hasn't seen me you know
they're always like oh wow Wow
and it's favorable it's a little
shocking but you know it's it's
interesting because now they realize
there's more to it to it than they first
thought right like you've got someone
pigeon-holed we always compartmentalize
go that's that's who Karen is okay yeah
right that's who dar is right and it's
just interesting I didn't mean to do
this
it just happened well I had a rough
summer two summers ago I had back pain
turned into back surgery in like 20 days
oh it was bad surgery wants
back tacular ly well pains gone
the I had something called foot drop so
it was literally nurse started to be any
of nerve damage all gone two weeks later
I had diverticulitis which I didn't even
know what the hell it was and and
basically they don't know what it is you
get a little bit of irritation in your
colon they don't know what causes it how
it occurs but I almost died from it yeah
not good and that got my attention that
got my attention I didn't like think oh
my god I almost died and make a big
thing out of it my mother grew up I grew
up with my mother was an ER nurse for 30
years and I see you for another two or
three years on top of that and then she
worked and managed health care for man
she worked and managed health care for
almost another thirty years after that
maybe 20 years or something like that so
I grew up in hospitals I was always at
the hospital you know we're gonna go see
mom or I had to go drop her off at work
or go pick her up as I started to drive
and stuff so I've always been around
that type of thing so I didn't like a
lot of people if they get it you know a
sniffle or a cough in the disparagement
that's the end of the world they're
dying oh do I have right now like no
take it easy you're gonna be all right
it's
so it made me indirectly think about
things and next thing I know I've got
long hair and stop shaving and I'm like
what am i doing
yeah but I could see you being just
you're now an author and and you write
you know science fiction or or just I I
think it works for you as well so I
thought you know it does or it doesn't I
I think it does I like it you know again
it's I you know what if one thing that's
come out of this also is I started to
look at this is gonna sound maybe
potentially crazy and that's okay that's
fine you are entitled to your opinions
looking at my life as performance art
living my life as a performance art
piece not just being weird I'll go I'm
gonna grow my hair now man yeah you know
I'm gonna dye my eyebrows baby like not
not that way and not that there's
anything wrong with that because
honestly deep inside of me when I was a
younger man I really wanted to do that I
admired those folks right
Kate Bush is not a performance artist
the first time I heard Kate Bush sing
what is happening blew my mind first
time I heard Al Jarreau start scatting I
was like you know still one of my
favorite albums of all time is is Al
Jarreau
live and it was in 77 look to the
rainbow unbelievable but I didn't do it
I was too scared for whatever reason
right but yeah I think that concepts
really kind of beautiful and I like it
and it's working for me right now
so I'm gonna keep doing more of that so
if the long hair and the beard and has
precipitated me looking at things from a
bigger perspective or start talking more
about a business aspect or transmedia or
living my life as a performance artist
so be it so be it you know it's just
interesting that youryour cast as
somebody that is really not who you are
in a lot of ways but but it seems like
it's very convincing but I can tell that
if just from being around you these
these few hours but that's not who you
are but you you just really can't judge
a book by it's cover because I would not
have if I saw you on the street I would
thought you know maybe you grew up in
Missouri or Texas or you know I would
not have you know a Midwestern guy or
what is from the south yeah and and just
to think that there's a whole another
world inside of you and that just is
very interesting because we don't know
about people walking around right that's
the most interesting thing that's where
that's where all the juices that's where
all the most beautiful stuff happens
right I told you earlier
so my father-in-law was a really great
man right and did an interview that in
in San Antonio and the girl afterwards
they wanted to look can we do a Facebook
live
I'm sure great let's do it and she says
uh so you know that must be really hard
you know you know those are big shoes to
fill I'm like well first of all I'm not
a black man I'm not a Christian I'm not
a minister I'm not a PhD in mathematics
all of which my father-in-law was and so
he is he and I I am I on me right second
thing is I'm not trying to fill his
shoes
mm-hmm right it's always over here but I
use it as motivation to keep going
forward right on his on his tombstone he
put down I tried that's what he wanted
to have his epitaph I tried I got excuse
me right right he certainly did try and
if he tried that hard and and what he
and uncle Martin did in in many ways
allowed my folks to even get together
right so in in a very real way I
wouldn't even be here were it not for
the Reverend and my mother-in-law
Juanita and uncle Martin on credit
wouldn't even be here right so I'm not
trying to fill their shoes I'm just I'm
trying man I'm doing the best I can keep
moving forward to do what I can do right
in whatever whatever way that's paws
so I mean I started to say this earlier
to kind of all over the place but I
decided that I was going to try to be
you know contribute and help and be of
service so I met some people and there's
this thing called Southern California
ceasefire and it's for victims of gang
violence and we meet in South South
Central once a week and it's a place
where everyone can get together and
share their stories and their pain or
what's going on or what kind of
activities going to be happening or if
there's going to be a rally if there's
gonna be a bake sale or a car wash or
whatever and of course you know someone
lost their son or their father or their
daughter or their mother and these are
people with real problems these are
people that are really suffering they're
not freaked out because oh my god did my
audition go badly right that puts things
in perspective rapidly right you know I
said earlier that um so I so I go down
there and I haven't been down there in a
while but I do go and I do put myself in
the middle of that and it's an
interesting mix because you've got the
victims families and that's raw and
that's palpable and it's I mean I don't
know what else to say about that
you've got LAPD they're plainclothes and
you've got a lot of undercover
you've got current gang members and
you've got old heads as they call them
who are out of the game and they're
trying to do best in fact they're the
ones who started the whole thing and
it's it's it's really interesting and it
really helps to keep perspective on
things and you know if this white boy
can go down there and talk and and just
eat just I didn't say anything for six
or seven months I just what am I going
to say what am I going to say Who am I
to say anything I'm just gonna listen to
you it's all I can do I can listen
that's as an actor by the way listening
is everything right the you I mean some
of it something I hear frequently and
I've heard Ben Kingsley say and if I've
heard Michael Caine say and I've heard
Helen Mirren say and I've heard Meryl
Streep say it you know stillness silence
and listening if you focus on only those
three things in your performance
everything will just start to blossom in
ways that you could never have hoped for
beautifully you know it brings
everything to life so I was like well
you know I'll sit down and I'm gonna
listen cuz that's all I can do and by
the way what am I gonna say that would
make me sound like the way I look like I
was short hair clean-shaven those days
right I look like the man you know so I
just said listen didn't say a word yeah
funny so our credit died I can't
remember the year right now it's been
it's been a minute and I just had a
surgery I had a hip surgery and I was
like doc I've got a flies like you can't
fly like I have got to go to her funeral
I cannot not be there and so you know we
got me on the medication and set her and
made sure I had plenty of painkillers
and stuff and so I'm hobbling along and
just incredible pain and I've got this
you know so my suit and tie on and clean
shaven short hair and I want you to know
the cops thought I was FBI uncle
Martin's attorney from back in the day
during the movement comes up and goes so
are you CIA are you FBI I don't think
we've met before I swear to God and I'm
hopped up on vicodin the pains out of
this world
I'm exhausted you know and and by the
way that funeral service lasted like
I'll I had tapped out at the six-hour
mark you know Stevie Wonder was sing and
I had to get up and go back and I sat
back up in this upper room where all the
cops were and I was literally in a suit
and tie on the floor with my leg in the
air and the cops are walking by me I
just remember looking up and there's
guns and holsters and
badges and bellies and hats no one would
have believed it it was crazy but yeah
yeah they thought I was a cop so I'm
walking into a situation like south of
Southern California ceasefire with gang
members ex-gang members old heads LAPD
the victims their families who the hell
is that guy what's that white boy doing
here
right and then as the word started to
get out all that to happen and II saw my
husband you know then okay oh yeah and
then they start talking me and they're
like and they find out oh well I'm half
Iranian you know my name is really Darya
Sh I knew you weren't white I was like I
think I'm white no man you a what you
ain't white yeah and then like that
broke down all the distrust in the fear
and the barriers really interesting man
and I and similarly when when when I was
going through tough times you know the
people that helped and listened to me
the most were the women why do you think
that is I'll throw it back in you why do
you think why would why would you think
and I'll answer the question I mean to
be coy why would a woman listen better
be able to more equipped to handle it
well typically were sort of more the
nurturers and the caregivers but that
doesn't mean men can't be as well and it
doesn't mean that women always are but
that's typically been our role and that
we're sort of taught to want to make
sure everybody's okay I don't know what
I did realize that's an old stereotype
and I so yeah it is yeah I agree and and
I I never looked at it necessarily that
way women the female energy is and
here's a man talking about it so forgive
me ladies my perspective you are much
more in touch with your emotions than
men are much more from an early age you
look at a 10 year old girl versus a 10
year old boy she's 10 going on 21 right
they understand social dynamics they
understand relationships
right those are critical things by the
way they're critical in all aspects of
life and especially in this business
right in any business right
relationships and my and walking
emotional minefields we step in them
quite often well everyone does right
uh-huh well women though you know they
think about you know you talked to one
why'd she do that and they start
breaking down the psychological reasons
and the emotional things that may be
going on you talk to guys like oh no you
know they don't they don't we like we
don't care until men to get hit seems to
be until we hit it like our mid 40s and
then if there's any hope it happens
right around there that you're gonna
start to understand so I'd come and
start talking about what was bothering
my guy friends like yeah cool what's on
TV
right and I was like right and I would
just go back into you know open
mouth-breather knuckle-dragging you know
let's drink a beer mode right now if I
talk to a girlfriend she'd lean into me
you know oh wow I'm like [ __ ] she's
listening to me right like wow oh my god
that must have been terrible or oh wow
you're so brave to do that or whatever
it was right and just in listening and
being empathetic which that feminine
energy has in a more beautiful way than
men men do even though I was sat here
and talked about my father-in-law and
Martin you know who certainly had it but
it was still masculine you know there's
just a beautiful thing there so anyway
because of that I decided I was going to
go down to the downtown woman's Center
in LA and similarly that didn't work out
so well either because I I kind of got
pulled aside and well I didn't get
pulled aside but I noticed that the
women were like there was they just
there was this visceral stay away from
me thing yeah and I was a little bit
older than it seemed to be like a lot of
younger kid
were there and stuff but yeah happens
it's understandable sorry I've been
through the wringer yeah they've been
through the wringer I was like okay well
that's not the way I'm gonna be able to
serve that situation I got to find
another way so
what should actors know before they get
into acting Wow if there's anything else
you can do think of yourself doing if
there's anything else that really
interests you you should really think
about looking at that more because
acting is extremely challenging and very
difficult to make a living at and it's
not for the timid it's just not and you
know there's no need to suffer
needlessly if you don't have a long-term
vision in your mind as to what you want
and where you're going with it and how
you're going to achieve that you know
and of course everything changes but if
there's anything else you'd rather do
you should think about rather doing that
if you can't if you are like me who
tried and it you know Here I am then you
have to play the long game and it's not
gonna be well I'm gonna give it five
months or I'm gonna give it two years no
no no no no no no no you may get lucky
you know some people I've been around
quite a few people who've got a break
and they're off to the races god bless
them that's great
they're the outlier they're the anomaly
that's not that that just doesn't happen
very often you know there's something I
saw I don't know if Hooper that what the
Screen Actors Guild got information
let's just say collectively now
sag-aftra has got I don't know 200,000
members out of those 200,000 members
only a certain number are working actors
and actresses right and what they deem
with the Union deems a working actor is
anyone who makes more than 5 thousand
dollars a year from acting jobs
Wow five thousand dollars which is why I
always say if there's anything else you
can think of doing go do it man cuz this
is what you're walking into
right so that's five percent of a
200,000 population of a union are
working and working means making more
than five thousand dollars now those
that are working and making more than
five thousand dollars that's an even
smaller
subset so I think you get down to like
1% Wow
it's tough it's really tough so I think
it would behoove anyone who gets in this
business especially an actor to realize
that you're in a business that those
numbers are the actual reality of what's
happening beyond the boots on the ground
where the rubber meets the road of this
business and that I just said business
and sorry I know I keep saying this
throughout this interview it would
really make sense to start to learn how
to be successful in business
you said timid earlier what's
interesting what's a timid actor versus
a non timid actor a timid actor do they
say that I thought you did maybe about
being timid about the business not so
much about the craft I think ah hmm
interesting
I don't know what timid Act well I mean
you know timid actor you're not gonna do
well if you're always fearful I don't
think I mean you don't have to be like
super you know gregarious outgoing you
can introverted there a lot of wonderful
actors that are completely introverted
and really shy and then you put a camera
on them and it's a whole different thing
or you put them on stage and she's who
is that and people just get blown away
and then when it's off they're just kind
of go right back into that shell I don't
know how folks like that make and I
think I really don't I don't know how
because you know the business part of
any you know businesses is not you know
warm and fuzzy and feel good however
when you see something a transformation
like that I know it's necessarily
attractive and it definitely catches
attention I don't know that that's I
mean it's it's not a it's not a
successful strategy you know it's one of
those outlier things again what do you
think happened to you in life that
prepared you for being able to take
rejection and and some of the the not so
warm and fuzzy things that happen and
business well I think you know I told
you that I started mowing lawns as a
young guy and and then had you know a
variety of different businesses and so
you know the lifeblood of any business
is sales nothing happens till the sale
occurs nothing right so in sales you
know you you're gonna get rejection
especially in the beginning I was
horrible
god I was bad and just like an
auditioning you know bad what audition
really is a sales job it really is and
you know I just wanted to do this so
badly from such a deep place and then I
began to enjoy it and love it more and
more and more that you know that fueled
my fire so the rejections yeah they suck
they hurt they frustrate they confound
they upset they confused they don't make
any sense
all at the same time and separately and
you know not at all and you know like I
said playing the long game you just got
to keep going right and then you know I
told you my background and we did we
moved a lot you know I don't I don't
know why I never got a straight answer I
don't my father but I think he kind of
got scared when he saw these four boys
and how much we ate and we ate a lot of
food I remember one time you know it was
great that we the grocery day was on
Saturday and and I went with my mother
to help her buy the groceries and this
is in the 70s and the grocery bill came
out to like two hundred and fifty
dollars in nineteen seventy dollars Wow
she got home and the old man saw the
receipt yeah he lost his mind
damn it what are you eating so much for
that she's like well they're growing
they need to eat and he just like and he
no you know he he he was upset but you
know he was like I think he was that was
his kind of battle cry to himself to
kind of sum it up you know his his blood
and get it going he needed to start
going out and get another job make more
money that's what he did to his credit
that's what he did to his credit
but stuff like that that all informs you
see that you know there are ups and
downs you're gonna get knows more than
you're going to get yeses but you learn
a lot in those noes
you really do
have you worked more in television or
film television hands-down yeah why do
you think some actors work more on
television and film I don't know that I
have the answer to that I don't know it
you know it's so challenging it's a
tough business you know they did it the
whole but there was no interview with
Matt Damon
Sam Jones's show I can't off-camera and
he said you know the business is
designed to keep you out it's the truth
right it's very challenging it's very
hard to get in so if you start working
in television and and that's you know
you dance with who brung you you know if
that's what it is if if it's a mixture
of both dance with who brung you right
do them do them both you know it always
amazes me where folks actors people
would ever think that like you can
choose to film and television well I'm
only going to do film I'm only going to
do television
I don't do television right I don't do
commercials right it's like that's
bananas you you you got to keep working
you've got to keep developing your skill
working those muscles out so to speak
metaphorically and you know whatever
happens happens you know and I don't
know that any actor goes on a single
we're making a film or we're just doing
a TV show yeah I've had those
conversations too but you still got a
job to do and one's not better than the
other is there a different energy on a
film set versus TV or no it's all the
same and sometimes in my experience I
mean yeah it's the same yeah you know
I've done yeah I mean I've done both you
know I don't know I've heard people
romanticizing to say you know films are
different because X Y & Z maybe yeah you
know maybe you're making a film you're
maybe a little bit you know it's a
little more precious because you still
got to make your day you know and you
still got to deliver and you know you
still got X Y & Z breathing down your
neck but that thing is going to be
around it's just it's viewed through a
different lens
to speak but that's really splitting the
atom fin Maya in my opinion yeah it's
it's really the same animal you know if
you start looking at well it's just a TV
show just the TV show like it's easy to
make a TV show and get it on the air we
said earlier about how commercials are
going away and yes I outs I'm seeing a
lot of names doing commercials
right and so I just find it interesting
is that because now they want sort of
that person become a face of the brand
uh we have a friend who is start saying
names but you would recognize him a
gnome right away and he's done
commercials and doesn't need to but you
know why wouldn't you right
the paydays great when you've got a name
and you're a celebrity and you know an
entity there's there's a brand there and
you know you can do a commercial we're
gonna speak general terms if I were you
know mr. movie star or mrs. movie star
and cereal Brand X comes up and says hey
you know we'd love you to be you know
our spokesperson or to do a series of
them for us and here you go here's you
know three million dollars why are you
gonna turn that down
right cuz someone's gonna call you a
sellout or or a worse word right I mean
I guess back back you know thirty forty
years ago you could say that and there
was a different time a different era and
okay fine but now why not that's as much
money as you make for you know you go
and you shoot a commercial you like take
a day and you shoot or three days a week
and you shoot you know five six spots
here you go there's three million
dollars yeah I always find the word
sellout as banding around by people that
probably haven't worked in a little bit
that this
it's such a baffling term to me who
wouldn't I mean it beats the alternative
I said this five times I'll say it again
let's be honest we're all so honest
sorry right I always say joking we're
all the [ __ ] for the dollar we're all
[ __ ] what's our price right yeah
alright so and it's fine if you think
that's selling out doing commercials you
know toothpaste dog food hair spray
whatever okay fine but you know you
don't know what's going on the other
person's life or with the other person's
sensibilities or values or beliefs are
or anything so you know and I don't
think anybody got this business just to
do a commercial or to only do passion
projects that don't pay I mean it's
great goes back into that narrative that
you said er you were speaking about
earlier how about how artists are
supposed to suffer man everybody suffers
in life artists don't have like it but
they don't have a I can't think of the
word they don't own that everybody
suffers and you don't have to suffer
needlessly right you're gonna you're
gonna get no you know knows that's
suffering constant rejections right
doing a bad audition having a you know
being on set and not doing that great a
job XY and Z and your part gets whittled
down to you know two words or just a
glance over a shoulder or something
stuff happens but you know you don't
have to sit there and just you know make
thing oh well you know I'm doing it more
for the you know speaking to my soul
that's all Graham King facetious but
yeah let us speak to your soul but don't
you know cut your nose off to spite your
face in the process all right yeah no I
I mean everybody suffers wealthy suffer
poor everybody has their own it's just
different sets of problems different
pressures that's it and so it's all
subjective yeah yeah pain is pain man if
it hurts if someone's in pain who the
hell are you to say that it shouldn't
hurt or it doesn't hurt that badly
what's a character you haven't played
yet that you'd like to not not so much
the show but a stereotype of our
composite
that you like you you know I want I want
it i want to break i want to do this
this time i want to do something that's
really challenging in that sense if one
gets the same roles over again doesn't
mean you can't still be creative within
that yeah but just something that like
is totally opposite that you really want
to try hmm interesting
you know the sonya i don't know i was
talking about this with the young actor
a couple of weeks ago and he was
wrestling with you know not wanting to
play a gay character well why not right
I would like I would do that in a
heartbeat right because I you know I
everyone has this kind of stereotype I
say everyone but it's not accurate that
a gay man is effeminate and speaks with
a list perhaps or is always banning his
hands around like this or whatever kind
of thing they might think and I just
think would be I was telling him I think
how much more interesting would it be if
you played yourself you just necessarily
happen to be gay that's true I mean
right so much more interesting right and
then you're opening space up for the
character to breathe and the audience to
come in and look at that a little
differently right and then within the
gay community there's very masculine
there's bears and I mean we're gonna
really getting technical but I grew up
in San Francisco so you know it but
there's very end just as with lesbians
there's lipstick lesbians it doesn't
have to be like one type so you know
yeah I mean the trans community was in
the Bay Area a long time ago yeah and
yeah I I have we have a friend who has
transitioned she used to be a man and
she's a champion race car driver oh wow
champion and transitioned and I want you
to know the hell that she has gone
through since that occurred
nascar through sponsors through fellow
drivers you know because they just can't
wrap their head around that thing that
occurred and who the person had was like
no man this is who this person was the
whole time that is not who the person
was right and that would be really
interesting I'd be really interesting
she has the courage of she's a Lionheart
I'm telling you man
trans the trans people I know in my life
are some of the bravest most courageous
empathetic people I've ever met you sit
down and talk to someone who's gone
through transitioning from one gender to
another I mean my god what must that
experience be like you know and there's
their family's reaction to it and what
do they still you know and just what if
they're abandoned and just having to
that happens a lot happens more often
than it doesn't that happens more often
than a dozen my you know in our family
my first brother came out sent a shock
wave through the family and I watched my
father start acting differently and I
watched my mother's start acting
differently and then I don't know it was
like a year or two years later the
second one came out and like everything
went for cockta with my folks you know
did just like up was down and left was
right and straight ahead was backwards
right and and they came around to their
credit but it was a bumpy road it was a
real bumpy road you know my father grew
up in Iran and in in Iran you know
there's a lot of homophobia which is
weird because when you're in Iran you'll
see men holding hands yeah when I see my
father I kiss him sure right yeah
sometimes on the lips on the cheek for
sure all right give him a hug every time
right and I remember watching my you
know my American friends and stuff they
just just kiss your dad man yeah yeah
well they wouldn't say another word I
didn't think about it until we need
years years later actually when my
brothers came out that I realized like
what was going on I was like god this
[ __ ] goes so deep in Iran it was not
uncommon to see soldiers in uniform you
know on an off day but still in their
uniform they're holding hands walking
down the street they're both straight
both straight but there's just you know
that cultural you know they're friends
they're brothers you know it wasn't
necessarily a homosexual thing in fact
if it were things would not have gone
well for them all right right and that's
another conversation but yeah anyway to
answer your question yeah I think that
would be interesting actually trans
would be really interesting I think it
makes a frightening woman we'd have to
get rid of the beard yeah you think
those eyes yeah we could play a mother
Wow okay yeah eyelashes nice yeah what
do you think yeah thanks would you date
me well maybe you know maybe you're not
my target market my avatar Lisa he's not
my Lisa
you are not my Lisa and we're not gonna
have two little girls and a pit bull an
aggressive aggressive pit bull summery
flowy I will not be wearing pastel
colors around you
do you know how to cry on cue yeah how
do you do it I pinch myself from the
testicles really hard okay it works
every time no so I couldn't help myself
I couldn't help myself you know it's not
it ah it's it's yeah it it you know on
case sounds so like once and now be cut
let's now be laughs well now we dance
you know sprocket yes sprocket say
exactly that's the ridiculousness of
that skit but there's so much more that
goes into it you know no one just good
need to cry on cue it sounds banaz okay
cry but it is that - it is that - but
there's you know there's the whole
dynamic of the story and the emotional
arc of of the character and what's
happening in the given moment and the
characters in the scene and what's
preceded it and you know that that
helped inform the whole thing and
ironically you know I I was been a scene
I'm crying and and I was laughing and
just making jokes the whole time in
between takes and I forget who it was
right I was the first ad or somebody
came up and started being the director
which that's so fun when that happens
yeah okay - it's a like man like you
know want to keep it together not too
much I'm like I didn't know you were
directing today I'm sorry hang on I
called the director over and like you
know just made it I just made fun of it
but just called it out and had fun with
it I wasn't trying to create his big
scene and I knew where he was coming
from and we were we were all cool I
still like the guy a lot but that was
part of my process right he was in my
mind now crying and laughing it's the
flip side of the same coin mm-hmm right
yeah it's the same coin it's the flip
side you're laughing here
you're crying there so I mean I don't I
don't analyze everything so intently but
for me I got to have fun
I got to do what I'm doing and we walk
around trying to be heavy and everything
else during the take or throughout the
day because I know that you know around
4 o'clock we're going to shoot that
scene and scene 52 is just it's you know
it's the emotional apex of that
character you're gonna get there and
your skin you know it won't go well for
you it won't
me I'm speaking for myself it won't go
well I've done it before but do you
think it's okay that some actors have
their own process in that they maybe
need to be more removed sure and because
I know something like this oh there they
won't come to sit there too but maybe
that's just their process yeah there's
like this weird stigma I think
yeah well all that happens that's for
sure that's happened you know someone
won't come to set or you know someone's
got earphones in they're listening to
whatever they're listening to or someone
won't even talk to you right that's
Hollywood in general that's only the
supermarket yeah it was just me but uh
yeah you got to respect the person's
process it's just you you know when you
start saying that the times that that
has happened like someone saw won't come
to set it's not about their process it's
not about yeah it's more about something
else
something else yeah yeah why I guess two
could depend on the level that that
person is that and what they're going
through and maybe are they gonna be hit
up for you know I mean it's exactly the
exact second understand there's a lot
right there's a whole lot going on and
and you know every time you start a new
job or you you know if it's day one of
the job and you're throughout the whole
process you know it's a new job it's a
new company it's a new production
everyone's got to get to know each other
right a friend of mine just started
doing a movie and the first day was a
little bumpy the second day was really
bumpy and so much so he's like oh my god
if this whole thing is gonna be like
this and he goes I'm just gonna go home
and have a drink and relax and you know
breathe and get up and see what tomorrow
brings me and sure enough smooth sailing
it was just that little bumpy rough
patch
you know that's another one of those
things that that you get to experience
in this business that you may not
necessarily in other businesses you know
usually it's you going to you know in
the in the real world so the speaker and
another industry you're the new person
you go to your job everyone else has
been there the building's been there the
dynamics that play the politics are at
play you have to learn how to fit in in
our industry everything's new the
politics haven't been established
necessarily or each department has their
own politics and then all the politics
when all the different departments come
together right that's a great point it's
gonna get bumpy it's gonna get messy
there are gonna be some storms there are
gonna be some wind windy days there
gonna be some really hot dry days you
just kind of keep breathing baby just
keep going through it you know all right
and typically people are usually on
their best behavior like the first few
days of something you would hope you one
would hope hello lovely to meet you
Karen once you know a bead and they're
working and they're great yeah but then
yeah you know people are people and
everybody has an ego and everybody gets
tweaked over certain things and it's
just it's it's usually about day three
or four someone has some bad chili and
the crew member farts in the middle of
your take oh okay well some Pepto Bismol
exactly but no so you things start to
happen so someone says something really
hilarious
breaks the ice the tension then the
conversations start to flow so when does
something that they shouldn't have done
oh no you know the judgment and the
criticism out stalling clicks and yeah
the passive-aggressive behavior and then
someone comes in that you know good
producer comes in and they're
psychologists and you know they're
negotiator and if they're not they learn
really quickly they ought to brush up on
that they come in and mend that before
it gets too messy
you know because there's a lot riding on
this yeah it's weird when you can kind
of feel there's like an on there's
unspoken clicks don't do you violate
that by trying to join the click or no
there's that like break sort of the
social mores or I don't know if that's
the right well I have a unique
perspective
I moved so much I was always the new guy
and I always felt that I always I had to
learn how to navigate that right away
and there is a time when it's okay to
insert yourself into that energy and
start talking and mingling with it and
there's a time where it's like now's not
the time right and you just don't want
it to to let the fear of of should I
shouldn't I should I shouldn't I should
I should and I should right just trust
your instinct your gut and you'll know
when the right time is because look
you're all there to create something
together and that's cool if that's there
click and you know you don't fit that
click you don't fit that click doesn't
mean you still can't be friendly that's
true
doesn't mean you still can't say hi and
respect their space and they respect
yours I saw this nice quote and it said
something like I'm butchering it but
just like saying hi to someone that you
don't like it's just being an adult
pretty much you know I was like you know
that there is a lot of truth in that
even if you have to kind of force it and
you're like yeah yeah and you're like
cool now they're over there that's great
but it's just being sort of like hey I'm
over here
I respect the fact that you're there
doesn't mean we have to be friends but
I'm just gonna say hi that's all it is
I know and so I thought that was
interesting so simple right
yeah so simple I know yeah sometimes
things in this business because it's a
more emotional you know nature because
you're creating art and emotions are
heightened because you're telling this
story that can kind of bleed over into
the real life you know because there's
the manufactured thing through the lens
that we're creating and then that's saw
that might bleed off into the real life
and people start to act stupid and it's
like wait a minute look all right
so-and-so is however they are doesn't
mean you can't just still be pleasant
and get through your day all right right
you don't you don't have to turn into
doesn't have to turn into a caddy thing
or you know this macho thing or this
aggressive thing doesn't have to be that
yeah yeah you think it comes from maybe
being more of the outcast then you then
you do you realize you don't what do you
mean
leave people out yeah you're like you
know what I don't
I'll say hi even though this isn't
really my kind of person but I'll say hi
and I live always aware of that mm-hmm
always aware of that but you know it's
part of me growing up you know when
you're the outsider you know you know
what that's like can be a lonely weird
you know uncomfortable place so I always
make an effort to go and talk to when I
see that person I just go over and test
the water see what's going on and
usually sometimes all you have to do is
listen just listen you know it's amazing
what happens when someone feels like
they're being heard you can just like
watch them blossom right in front of you
I you know I here's an interesting story
I just thought fine
I wanted to get a day job this was on a
20 some odd years ago and and I had a
business with my folks was a small print
and copy shop I knew nothing about it
but I took all the failures of my other
businesses and and did the opposite of
that and did really well with it and we
were able to raise the business up quite
a bit
drive you know make it much more
profitable and my folks were able to
sell it off and retire and so I thought
well you know I'll go see about this
copier job so I went to this company out
Shawn remain nameless and for an
interview and I walked in she goes oh
just fill out the application and you
know mr. X will see you shortly and I
was like oh no that's okay I'm not I
don't fill out the application I've
already got my you know CV with me my
whatever she just kind of looked at me
sat down way did I catch ants to go and
sat down with mr. X really nice man and
it was the job was just it was terrible
they're gonna give me the worst I know
what they're gonna do they're gonna be
the worst territory and there's gonna be
business that you know business business
sales and I'm gonna try to get them to
buy copiers from this company and the
the pay was gonna be nothing there
wasn't going to be a car allowance or
cell phone allowance or laptop allowance
or insurance or any you know benefits or
medical or dental or anything and I was
like that you know I get it I know the
drill but I'll show my worth and you
know things will change well we've done
this listening exercise in an acting
class I was doing at the time and and it
was really mind-blowing and when we did
it for me it was because I had an
experience with the actress that I was
working with that that night and I just
watched this whole shift occur in her I
didn't say anything she was just talking
and I was listening with a hundred
percent focus which by the way just
doing that it's almost it's exhausting
the first time you do it but it was also
really interesting and liberating and so
I thought I'm gonna try that today so
instead of this interview and we say a
few pleasantries back and forth
and he says well tell me about yourself
I go well you know there's a lot of you
say about myself but you know I would
really like to hear like what your
biggest challenges are who's been great
at this job who's not being great at
this job anything that you could share
with that be really helpful to me and I
don't want to waste your time and and I
certainly wouldn't dream of wasting your
time I think that was like that would
the totality of what I said and then I
didn't say another word for 45 minutes
and he just started to talk it was a
little bit like you know I could see him
as my life what the hell is this right
yeah who is this guy right which would
you know it's actually like a really
smart move I wasn't trying to be smart
or anything or saying I'm necessarily
smart but anyway all I did for the next
45 minutes late mm-hmm oh really
Wow but I was actively listening there
are things you can do and we'll get into
it here that you you train yourself to
actively listen and eye contact total
focus and I'm literally hearing
everything you're saying and I did that
for 45 minutes with this guy and he just
kept opening up more and more and smile
came across his face about five minutes
in and it wouldn't leave 20 minutes in
he's telling me funny stories and
anecdotes about his family and stuff and
it just kept on going at about the 45
minute mark I remember that well because
you know what man I'm not gonna give you
this position I can't this position man
you're better than this I can't do that
to you and that broke me for a second I
didn't speak but I was like what did he
just say and I went right back to listen
he goes listen man this is the worst
this is the worst position I'll tell you
what I want you to come and meet the
president the company company he's got
to meet you hang on one second and you
got a billion I was like oh my god
what's going on
it goes down he gets the president he
calls me Mike we walked down with the
presidents obviously introducing the guy
and the guys like I heard great things
about you yeah we'd love to have you on
board and I've given him full full
authority to give you you know this
route and out of this district this
territory I'm like okay well great nice
to meet you
they sat me down and they offered me
this like really great job I mean there
was the first
was like a $30,000 a year job and I
ended up they offered me like I want to
say eighty-five thousand a year plus
bonuses and Commission which were end up
being I don't know like around 150 a
year maybe more this is you know 20-some
odd years ago with a car with insurance
with the cellphone with a laptop full
benefits right out of the gate in one of
their best territories did you take it
no no - and there's two reasons why
number one I was stunned I couldn't
believe that just happened
I I was just doing this acting listening
exercise that this is Wow
and I was just kind of trippin because
of what had happened with the actress
and I when we were doing this exercise
the night before both of us fully aware
of what was going on but she couldn't
help it she the same thing that happened
to her on a much more personal level
happen in the room with that gentleman
with Mr X and I just Wow
and I thought about is like I can't do
that yeah that's like it that's a job
job man what am I gonna go do this I
can't take time off and work I can't go
to audition in the middle of the day
when they're I can't do that and so I
you know respectfully decline he goes
don't listen I you're a winner you're on
your I didn't say anything
I just listen to the man did you ever
think about that job if there were a few
bumpy times and say I should have taken
it or were you even glad when there were
bumpy times I'm glad I never cuz that's
a full committed career well yeah it is
yeah there he was like me listen you
you'd have my job I'm kind of glad he
said you'd have my job in six months if
you were here I can see it in your eyes
I did you know I probably a mixture of
both back and forth you know when I was
like oh my god but ironically when I
decided not to take that job
I just kind of went on a tear and
started working back to back to back to
back to back and yeah but yeah I mean
that would have been nice in a lot of
ways I remember there's that you know
the class I was in that occurred I
mentioned to the guy who was teaching
the class about that
and he's are just a real like wrestling
with his own demon well that's all I'll
say was no he's the most pleasant cat
which was one of the reasons I bike like
I can't be with this guy and it was kind
of a bittersweet because I this exercise
that we had done I thought this is so
amazing
however you know the personality leaves
so much to be desired I don't want to be
around that anymore
so but I just I'm getting ahead of
myself so I told the guy what had
happened in this you know job interview
like four or five days before and he
looks and he goes don't do that stay in
this business you stay here keep doing
this and I was like the nicest thing
he'd ever said I was like first of all
where the hell did that come from
thank you but where the hell did that
come from I was like I don't know it was
interesting interesting it's interesting
when you have someone that doesn't have
to be nice to you and they end up giving
you a compliment I think it's oh yeah it
is you're right but I think that guy
should be nice because he's taking money
from people to provide a service and
behaving opposite of that yeah sure I'm
not that guy I'm not I hear you I can't
be around that that I can't be around
that guy or that gal do you think all
actors should have acting classes or can
they take breaks sure of course take
breaks again your your way is your way
you don't to get stuck in taking class
class Phil oh I gotta take another class
it's gonna go take this class now and
then hey everything will be great
you learn more yeah I'm gonna say
something it's going to upset some
acting teachers maybe not one the ones
of substance will understand this
I would recommend that an actor in lieu
of paying I don't even know how much
acting classes cost these days but let's
let's say it's you know five six hundred
dollars a month something like that
right take that money and go invest it
in a filmmaker that's got a project that
you like or create one for yourself and
go shoot a short or go shoot a
full-length invest in their film and go
learn on set
there's no acting class like that now
it's not gonna be the best thing in the
world of course messy everything else
but that's how you get better that's how
you get better there's nothing like
seeing yourself seeing your work and
seeing the finished product to teach you
what you need to learn you know I know a
lot of external I can't watch dailies I
can't see myself man I'd love to see him
I don't get a chance the same enough all
right I've gotten past the point oh god
I look like X Y or Z yeah well I look
how I look whatever right if I can see
the performance in the monitor if I can
see it then that's gonna help because if
you know you as an actor you can hear
you can see in the directors eyes
they're not getting what they want or
something's happening or you're doing
something with your your ear you know or
your you're sitting a certain way or
whatever right if I can hear it and see
it I can remedy it you don't have to
give me a direction so but anyway I
would say do that take your money go
invest in a film you know don't expect
to ever see it again but you might get
more out of that than you get out a
month of acting class and you're working
and you have finished taping it's all
done boom that just happened well how
can you tell when an acting class isn't
for you maybe it's not a bad teacher or
a bad when it becomes psychotherapy when
it becomes lording themself over you
which happens quite frequently I can't
tell you how many acting classes I've
seen around town or that that the
teachers got their chair positioned
under literally under a light maybe
elevate it a little bit you know
and all under the guise of will you know
I want to be able to see you and be able
to talk to everybody and see them cool
story bro cool story right you could
easily do that by standing up and
walking around too you know you don't
think you put yourself on an elevated
position because psychologically there's
a lot going on when that happens it's
like watching someone on stage you know
the great Sun God is talking to us we
must listen now you know and that
happens happens a lot but yeah well
anytime you get into a class they start
playing psychotherapy with you like the
great there's a great show on TV right
now Barre on HBO genius Henry Winkler
when is Emmy for playing the
conglomeration of all bad acting
teachers and of course some good acting
teacher in balled-up in one with his
character and sorry about that and you
know he it's hilarious to watch that but
you know anytime someone starts to try
to break you down psychologically or
emotionally you're on a slippery slope
there that's not a trained professional
that's not a trained mental health
professional and PS a lot of them are X
actors or still want to be actors or
failed actors and this is what they do
now and that's fine man I don't begrudge
any of that just don't start becoming
something you're not if you see that
happening in a class just walk out just
get up and walk out yeah just keep it
about the work that's being done I just
said the work that used to drive me nuts
but just keep it about the words on the
page the place location the characters
keep it about that you got mental blocks
you've got emotional blocks that's on
you baby work it out but for an acting
teacher to come in and like what is it
that your mother didn't do to you and
those how many conversations have I
heard like that oh my god
what are you doing you know just I've
seen him leave
actors and actresses just wrecked
afterwards not cool
dangerous in fact you have seen teachers
and other people break people down to in
front of the class not just acting
teachers but another there was one
scenario I won't name what it is but I
felt horrible for the woman and it was
this group thing where they ganged up on
her and told her what she should do and
and and but I think that's similar that
can happen in these acting classes it's
it's like we talked about a little bit
mob mutt that mob mentality and you know
here we go again I've never talked about
this on camera but you guys have got an
exclusive with this but this going
through this cult and then getting you
know myself you know working through
that and healing myself of it coming out
of that it's a lot of work man and so
yeah I had to find out what had happened
to me and that's that you literally just
described the dynamic at play within
that group thank you no emotional
manipulation controlling the words the
milieu as they say right it's a slippery
slope
you know it's a slippery slope so you
always have to watch out for that you
know when you're young and energetic and
maybe not so worldly and maybe a little
naive but God knows I was God knows I
was yeah clearly I was well there's
wanting to be accepted to that's right
you could be incredibly worldly and not
but there's also this you know everybody
has a need to be accepted that's right
you know but it's been said you know in
studying all these really well-known
psychologist and and psychology and
linguists and stuff like that if you
break down the two issues that are at
the core of every being everything
breaks down to two issues right well I
got my mother issues and I got my daddy
issues and oh you know alcohol and you
know the x y&z but it all boils down to
two things number one I'm not lovable
and number two is I'm not worthy slash
good enough so I'm not good enough
worthy and I'm not lovable that's the
core of everything and all of us have it
and all of us wrestle with it yeah be
your own friend
be nice to yourself give yourself a
break Jesus dr. Wayne Dyer dr. dark
Dixon yeah pulling your on stranger yeah
amazing yeah didn't mean to get preachy
but it's the truth it is I know but it
may sound however it may sound but you
know that's the reality I think it's a
certain people they haven't experienced
certain things yet my thing is I've seen
people either experienced things early
I've said this before but either early
in life that really shapes them that's
traumatic or they get it later because
no one no one ever has a totally smooth
ride I don't think but I think the ones
that have it first those first initial
things I think it can be traumatic but
can also help you later on whereas the
ones that haven't had it yet and then it
happens later I think that actually
might be more detrimental you're talking
about in childhood yeah just in terms of
rough childhoods frequently well it
I say frequently but there are a lot of
really successful people financially
socially spiritually what you name it
across the board physically etc Western
definition of success
Eastern definition of success whatever
it may be for you who had horrible
childhoods horrible and they used that
as fuel to propel them right because
nothing in and of itself has any meaning
except the meaning we give to it going
back to that again right I know other
people who had a horrible childhood it's
unspeakable and they just won't let
themselves get beyond that meaning
they've given to it right I must not be
lovable I must not be good enough right
yeah just like I don't even know if they
look at it that way I don't even know if
they look at it that way but yeah yeah I
sometimes used to think I used to be
like I wouldn't wish but I was like
maybe if I had a really rough childhood
like really rough around
really successful how crazy is that
every you know everybody has something
I've had I thought yeah yeah some people
they get it early and maybe not so much
later I don't know that's just my theory
it doesn't mean it's and other people I
think it happens later I think that part
might be tougher but maybe I'm on yeah
it will happen though no one no one gets
out of this life unscathed I mean you
said Buddhism right what's the first
noble truth life is suffering far wiser
person than me if that's what they're
saying I should probably listen to it
sure yeah doesn't mean that's what it is
but life certainly you're not going to
escape it and that's taken out of
context that's not what the Buddha said
but right right that's right